Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zu Ausgabe 143 von UKW.
Und wenn ich überraschend, wollen wir hier euch ein Update zur Situation der
Welt, unserer kleinen Welt liefern.
Euer ganz persönliches Auslandsjournal. Das mache ich natürlich mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo.
Und ja, wir wollen ein wenig mal zusammenfassen, was so in der Ukraine passiert
ist, aber wir müssen natürlich auch den Elefanten im Raum abräumen.
Werdet ihr sicherlich schon von gehört haben, dass die USA gemeinsam mit Israel
den Iran angegriffen hat und
das haben sie zwar schon im Dezember mal kurz gemacht für ein paar Tage,
aber jetzt knallt es halt so richtig und jetzt sind die Konsequenzen schwerwiegend.
Und ja, um mal zu gucken, was jetzt wieder mit dem Dritten Weltkrieg so auf sich hat,
tauchen wir mal ein wenig ein und geben euch mal so unsere Zusammenfassung und
Reflexion, was wir uns so für Gedanken gemacht haben darum und was es so noch
anderes dazu zu erzählen gibt.
Aber erstmal richten wir kurz den Blick auf die Ukraine.
Wir hatten jetzt die letzte Sendung am 19. Februar rausgehauen und das war ja
alles so ein bisschen unter dem Aspekt,
dass jetzt Starlink sich dazu genötigt sah oder selbst entschieden hat,
was auch immer da die Motivation war letztlich,
den Russen den Hahn abzudrehen.
Und ja, das hatte dann doch einige Auswirkungen auf diesen Krieg und das haben
wir ja auch letztes Mal schon angedeutet, dass die Ukraine das genutzt hat,
um so ein paar Gegenvorstöße vorzunehmen.
Ja und jetzt stellt sich raus, dass das nicht nur mal so eben eine kurze Reaktion
war, sondern dass dahinter offenbar sogar eine etwas ausgefeiltere Taktik steckt,
Und das hat jetzt dazu geführt, dass an der Front,
an der Front, wo.
Was eigentlich Donetsk, die Donetsk-Front noch ist, aber wo es sozusagen schon
nach Saporizhia rüber geht oder was Nipro-Region,
Nipro-Pretrovsk, das weiß ich gerade gar nicht.
Ich gucke mal kurz nach, damit wir euch hier keinen Unsinn erzählen und ich
kann es gar nicht beantworten hier mit den Daten, die ich gerade habe.
Auf jeden Fall gab es diesen Move der Ukraine, hier die Kommunikationslücken
auszunutzen und es sieht aber so aus, als ob eine etwas ausgefeiltere Strategie dahinter steckt.
Und die hat eben viel damit zu tun, dass ja, wie wir ja schon seit längeren
Berichten und immer wieder sehen.
Ukraine so ihr Drohnengeben halt weiter hochfährt und wohl mittlerweile das
so gut koordiniert bekommt,
dass sie jetzt so eine Art Combined Warfare machen mit Drohnen und Infanterie.
Das heißt, sie nutzen jetzt nicht nur diese Kommunikationslücke aus oder vielleicht
auch das, das kommt noch sozusagen mit dazu, sondern sie greifen in bestimmten
Bereichen massiv mit Drohnen an.
Das tun sie ja in gewisser Hinsicht schon die ganze Zeit, weil ja diese gesamte
Grayzone, also dieser gesamte Bereich, wo weder die Ukraine noch die Russen
das Gebiet wirklich kontrollieren,
sondern sich quasi so auf Distanz gegenüberstehen und alles mit Drohnen überwacht wird.
Diese erst 20, mittlerweile glaube ich fast 50 Kilometer breiter Streifen,
die man überall sehen kann und jetzt gehen sie dort rein und...
Haben aber nicht Drohnen überall, also das haben sie nach wie vor,
sondern konzentrieren richtig große Drohnenschwärme, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt.
Das könnte jetzt so verstanden werden, dass das jetzt wirklich so richtige Schwärme
sind, wo die Drohnen untereinander sich koordinieren.
Das meine ich nicht, sondern es wird so davon berichtet, dass so bis zu 300
Drohnen, also dann auch mit 300 Operatoren gleichzeitig in ein bestimmtes Gebiet reinfliegen,
dort halt die Stellung der Russen, die man ausgemacht hat, vorher schon wusste
oder in dem Moment erst entdeckt, die direkt angreift, sodass die in diese Defensive geschickt werden.
Und dann aber sofort mit Infanterie nachzieht, also jetzt auch wirklich mal
wieder militärisches Personal aufbringt und die Russen nicht nur jetzt bekämpft aus der Distanz,
sondern Distanzbekämpfung und ein unmittelbares Nachrücken.
Und das hat den Effekt, dass sie also auf ziemlich breiter Front in der Lage sind,
richtige Lücken in diesen von den Russen kontrollierten Bereich reinzuwerfen
und angeblich sei jetzt im letzten Monat halt mittlerweile ein Bereich von ungefähr
400 Quadratkilometern zurückerobert worden.
Klingt viel, aber so 20 mal 20 Quadratmeter.
Genau, also 20 mal 20 Kilometer so.
Und das ist jetzt nicht nichts, aber die Ukraine ist groß und die Russen haben
in dem Sinne mal wieder Gebiet abtreten müssen.
Und es bleibt abzuwarten, ob diese Strategie vielleicht an anderen Stellen auch
noch funktionieren könnte.
Das heißt aber jetzt nicht, dass die Russen nicht auch selber wiederum Landgewinne
machen und da sie ja mittlerweile die Städte Prokowsk und Myrnograd, diese Doppelstadt,
wo sie sich jetzt irgendwie zwei Jahre drum die Köppe eingeschlagen haben,
eingenommen haben und weiter im Westen auch die Stadt Huljapolle, Wie auch immer,
auf jeden Fall dort drücken sie nach wie vor gen Westen und das ist nach wie
vor etwas beunruhigend, weil das eben bedeutet, dass sie sich der großen Stadt Saporizia nähern.
Sind aber noch relativ weit weg, aber das kann man nicht vorstellen,
dass da nicht auch demnächst nochmal gegen gehalten wird.
Aber es wird zumindest davon berichtet, dass die Russen sich jetzt darauf konzentrieren
und da viele Truppen zusammenziehen.
Muss man jetzt mal abwarten, wie das so ausgeht.
Aber diese neue Taktik verspricht zumindest einen Wechsel in der Art und Weise,
wie dieser Krieg geführt wird und man muss mal gucken, ob das jetzt nur so ein
kurzzeitiges Phänomen ist oder ob das vielleicht die Vorbereitung auf einen
größeren Strategiewechsel ist.
Ja, das Problem könnte natürlich sein, dass die Russen das eventuell kopieren könnten.
Die kopieren ja sehr viel von der Ukraine und umgekehrt auch,
wenn man sieht, dass das funktioniert.
Wobei natürlich 300 Drohnen-Operator auf einem, ich sag mal,
mehrere Kilometer breiten Frontabschnitt nur zu konzentrieren und dass die dann
auch noch effektiv in der Lage sind zusammenzuarbeiten,
das erfordert dann schon eine
Menge gut ausgebildeter und erfahrener Drohnenpiloten, das durchzuziehen.
Und die kann man natürlich nicht einfach so aus dem Hut zaubern.
Und nicht nur die Drohnenpiloten selber, sondern der Trick hier ist ja,
dass das Ganze eben auch noch mit dem Vorschreiten der Infanterie verbunden ist.
Und das würde ich sagen, ist definitiv ein Bereich, in dem die Russen gerade nicht so brillieren.
Ja, also man muss das zumindest vorher auch trainiert haben und ausprobiert haben.
Das ist nicht ganz so einfach, aber es ist halt grundsätzlich so eine alte Taktik.
Wie gesagt, Rolling Thunder nannte man das früher so im Ersten Weltkrieg,
wo man dann eben mit Artillerie vorne weggeschossen hat und dann die Infanterie hinterhergezogen.
Aber da muss man, wenn man es mit
Artillerie macht, natürlich viel Abstand halten, zeitlich und räumlich.
Und mit den Drohnen, weil man sieht, was man macht, kann man halt mit den Drohnen,
ziemlich nah ran oder so rum.
Die Infanterie kann ziemlich nah an die Drohnen ran und hinterher,
weil es halt nicht wie Artillerie ist, sondern die können da nicht zehn Meter
hinter der Drohne herlaufen,
wenn es sein muss.
Ja, nicht, wenn sie dann explodiert.
Naja, aber...
Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall alles, hat eine ganz andere Dynamik Und von daher
muss man mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ja, des Weiteren bei den sonstigen Angriffen im Hinterland gibt es jetzt einen neuen Trend offenbar.
Wir hatten ja jetzt in den letzten Monaten vor allem sehr viele Angriffe auf die Ölinfrastruktur.
Die gibt es auch nach wie vor. Was aber sehr auffällig ist, dass die Ukrainer
jetzt einige ziemlich massive Angriffe gemacht haben mit Attack-Ams.
Und mit den ballistischen Raketen der Amerikaner und dann die Storm Shadows,
die britischen Cruise Missiles und damit gezielt auf die russische Rüstungsindustrie gehen.
Und zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt die Standorte, wo die Panzer gebaut werden,
die sind nämlich weiter hinten im Hinterland, sondern zum Beispiel jetzt gerade
in Belgorod eine relativ wichtige Hersteller von Elektronikbauteilen.
Wo dann irgendwie der Chef selber noch vor ein paar Wochen im Video damit geprahlt
hat, wie wichtig sie doch sind und wenn es die nicht gäbe, dann gäbe es ganz
viele Waffen nicht mehr in Russland.
Hoffen wir mal, dass er recht hat, weil nach dem letzten Angriff scheint von
dieser Fabrik relativ viel zerstört worden zu sein, relativ wenig übrig geblieben zu sein.
Das waren schon massive und gut koordinierte Schläge.
Also Das zeichnet sich so ein bisschen als Trend ab.
Ja, und auch auf diverse Chemiefabriken und auch wohl auf eine Fabrik,
wo dann halt der Treibstoff für Raketentriebwerke gemischt wird,
also für Feststoffraketen.
Da brauchst du halt so Maschinen, wo dann die Rakete halt drauf rollt im Prinzip.
Also wenn du jetzt so eine Feststoffrakete füllst, dann musst du halt vorher
so Schichten auf, also diverse Isolationsschichten aufbringen, gleichmäßig.
Und das wird gemacht,
indem man dann die Hüllen quasi in Rotation versetzt und während das Ding rotiert,
füllt man dann diverse flüssige oder sehr flüssige Pasten ein und die dann aber
durch die Zentrifugalkraft dann einigermaßen gleichmäßige Schichtdicken bilden Und ja.
Wenn nur diese und so eine Fabrik eben wurde, dann auch angegriffen.
Plus, du brauchst halt gewaltige Mischer, auch die gleichmäßige Mischungen herstellenden
von dem Raketentreibstoff und was auch immer eingefüllt wird.
Und ja, es war jetzt nicht super Hightech, aber es jetzt tut halt auch weh,
wenn man also man braucht es halt man kann keine Raketen bauen.
Ja, dann vielleicht auch nochmal ein kurzer Blick auf diese Abschaltung von dem Starlink.
Es gab jetzt eine veröffentlichte Statistik, dass wohl in der Region der Starlink-Traffic
insgesamt um 75 Prozent zurückgegangen ist.
Das würde dafür sprechen, dass
die Russen dann doch sehr intensiv Nutzen gezogen haben aus dem Starlink.
Jetzt wie gesagt nicht mehr.
Bei der Kommunikation, also dieses Telegramm, diese Abschaltung von Telegramm,
die angekündigt wurde und die teilweise schon so durchgesetzt wurde,
dass halt keine Bilder und Videos mehr gesendet werden kann,
die ist wohl noch nicht final erfolgt, aber soll nach wie vor gemacht werden.
Russland möchte gerne, dass alle diese Max-App benutzen, was irgendwie keiner will.
Und alle klagen, also sogar Vertraute mittlerweile des Kremls klagen,
dass ja hier irgendwie die Propaganda ja dann nicht mehr über die Landesgrenzen
schwappen kann, wenn kein Telegram mehr benutzt wird.
Ja, okay, das sieht mir wirklich so ein bisschen nach einem Eigentor aus und
ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich
das nicht so ganz genau, aber die Angst vor freier Kommunikation im Volk.
Scheint wohl größer zu sein als die Erschwerung der Offensive.
Da kann man jetzt viel reinlesen, weil ich meine dieses Argument würde man ja
meinen im Krieg so, ja wollen wir es noch schwieriger machen für unsere Soldaten
an der Front zu kommunizieren.
Lass mal die Kommunikation abschalten, nachdem schon die externe abgeschaltet wurde.
Klingt nicht wirklich nach einer guten Idee, aber vielleicht ist es ja auch
so ein Zeichen von Panik, dass man irgendwie sagt, wenn wir jetzt nicht alles
auch in der Bevölkerung unter Kontrolle bekommen, sind wir nicht mehr sicher
genug gegen irgendeinen Stimmungsumschwung.
Ich will jetzt nicht von Putsch reden oder so, das kam auch an der einen oder
anderen Stelle schon mal so als Spekulation, das halte ich für ein bisschen übertrieben.
But you never know. Unsere These war ja schon immer, diese Regime halten sich
halt super, bis sie das dann von 0 auf 100 auf einmal sich nicht mehr halten können.
Und Putin ist sich sicherlich seiner Gegner immer sehr bewusst.
Also keine Ahnung, was da drin steckt. Auch WhatsApp ist wohl eingeschränkt
worden und generell ziehen die,
Ja, ziehen sie da irgendwie die Grenzen immer enger.
Ja, und dabei ist es eigentlich ziemlich dumm, weil sie teilweise eigentlich
sich recht gut auch schlagen auf diesen Plattformen.
Also die russische Propaganda dort ist wirklich nicht von schlechten Eltern, muss man sagen.
Und ja, gerade vor allem,
wie du gesagt hast, so in den Nachbarländern oder anderen ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken,
was weiß ich, wie Kasachstan und so weiter,
wo eben sie bisher mit ihrer Propaganda reingehen konnten oder auch einfach Austausch stattfand.
Und ja, die werden sie nicht auf den Max-Messenger umbiegen können.
Sie werden sich nicht Max installieren, um russische Propaganda weiterhin hören zu können.
Das ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Und ein anderes eben riesiges Problem, das wir schon letztes Mal auch schon
angesprochen haben, dass halt sehr viel auch von den zivilen Gruppen,
die jetzt Material für die Soldaten an der Front einsammeln und Spenden einsammeln,
die es ja auch auf russischer Seite gibt,
die sind fast nur auf Telegram unterwegs und seit Jahren und.
Was es ihnen jetzt auch noch die Sache erschwert, Russland verfolgt jetzt Leute,
die im letzten halben Jahr Anzeigen auf Telegram geschaltet haben.
Weil Telegram damals zu einem feindlichen Agenten oder Terrorförderer oder so erklärt wurde.
Und wenn du dort dann eben bezahlte Werbung geschaltet hast,
was halt viele dieser Initiativen auch getan haben, die jetzt Kohle einsammeln,
dann kannst du jetzt wegen Förderung einer terroristischen Organisation oder
Terrorfinanzierung verfolgt werden.
Da sind sie natürlich auch nicht gerade glücklich drüber.
Wie vielen Fällen das tatsächlich zu Problem führt, schwer zu sagen.
Aber es gab wohl Fälle oder es gibt wohl Fälle, wo jetzt Leute Hausbesuche gekriegt
haben, weil sie eben in Russland sitzen und auf Telegram-Anzeigen geschaltet haben.
Also zumindest Verfahren eingeleitet worden. Ja.
Läuft super. Ja, dann noch ein kurzer Blick auf die Entwicklung der Waffentechnik.
Da gab es ein paar interessante Entwicklungen, also sicherlich noch mehr,
als wir jetzt hier ansprechen, aber das fand ich jetzt bemerkenswert.
Also diese...
Also ukrainische Waffentechnik jetzt.
Ja, in dem Fall bezieht sich das jetzt nur auf die Ukrainer.
Einerseits diese Firepoint, also eins der Rüstungsunternehmen in der Ukraine,
die liefern wohl gut ab.
Und diese FP1 und FP2 Drohnen sind gerade immer wieder im Gespräch,
insbesondere bei Angriffen fern im, tief in Russland.
Also sie haben eine extreme Durchdringungstiefe und können auch schon relativ
viel Sprengstoff mit sich führen.
Es gibt ja diese FP1 und FP2.
Die FP2 ist im Prinzip nur die größere Version von der FP1 und sie haben jetzt
die wohl so umgebaut, dass sie jetzt den Tank...
In die Flügel verlegen und damit mehr Platz haben für Sprengstoff.
Das heißt, die Dinger werden jetzt auch nochmal 50% mehr Wumms entwickeln.
Und während es jetzt nicht so viel Neues gibt zu dieser FP5,
also zu dieser sogenannten Flamingo Cruise Missile, sind aber jetzt so erste
Tests veröffentlicht worden mit der FP7.
Und das ist dann eine ballistische Rakete und das wäre dann ja ein Novum.
Also das ist jetzt noch nicht so die Mega-Reichweite, ich glaube,
was war das, 600 Kilometer oder sowas, aber das ist natürlich etwas,
was den Ukrainern in ihrem Arsenal noch fehlt.
Also klar, die haben Attack Games von den Amerikanern, aber da hängen sie sozusagen
von den anderen ab und von Europa bekommen sie da halt gar nichts.
Und wenn sie jetzt in der Lage sind, selber in nennenswerter Menge ballistische
Raketen zu produzieren und die auch zum Einsatz zu bringen,
dann hat Russland ein neues Problem, weil sie sich dieser Technik bisher,
also das, was von externer Produktion rüberkam, sehen wir schon,
da haben sie gar nicht so eine gute Verteidigung.
Und wenn die Ukrainer das noch hochschrauben können mit einer eigenen Produktion,
dann wird es noch dünner die Luft an der Stelle.
Also da toben im Moment auch so ein bisschen die russischen Propagandisten.
Dass speziell auch UK wohl da mehr als nur finanzielle oder ideelle Hilfe geleistet hat.
Also die Flamingo wird bei den Ukraine-Krieg-Kritikern im Westen eigentlich
als englische Waffe bezeichnet,
die eigentlich in den UK entwickelt wurde und dann ja.
Und plus, dass halt, ja, natürlich hier mit Storm Shadow,
dass das englische Waffen sind und dass das überhaupt in England auch andere
Waffensysteme, gerade auch wohl Firepoint-Drohnen,
dass dort auch massiv Teile für produziert werden oder wohl angeblich komplette
Raketen dort gebaut werden.
Dass ja eigentlich jetzt Russland das Recht hätte, irgendwelche englischen Dörfer
zu bombardieren, weil das legitime Ziele jetzt sind, weil die Waffen dort für
die Ukraine bauen und bla bla.
Ja, und das ist dann nachrecherche, zumindest was die Flamingo angeht,
ist da ein bisschen was dran.
Also, da wurde tatsächlich ein fast identisches System vorgestellt auf einer
Rüstungsmesse von einer englischen Firma,
lange bevor das als Flamingo rauskam und die Firma,
die das halt vorgestellt hat,
bietet das auch noch immer an.
Und ja, also, aber gut.
Muss man aber dazu sagen, dass die Flamingo ja mit alten Raketentriebwerken
funktioniert, die die Ukrainer noch von einem anderen System auf Halde hatten, soweit ich das weiß.
Also es ist schon, aber da mag so die Steuerungstechnik etc. mit reingekommen sein.
Also was auch, also mal halt sozusagen aber auch die Grundidee so von den Abmessungen
her und so weiter und wahrscheinlich haben Sie ja dann komplett jetzt andere Technik drin,
aber sagen wir das Grunddesign zumindest, ja.
Ja, ist etwas älter.
Ja, dann noch eine Kleinigkeit, das ist noch kein richtiges Phänomen,
aber da ist ein Video aufgetaucht, das meine Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat,
dass wohl die ukrainische Armee mittlerweile testet mit Lasern die Fiberoptik
Drohens auszuschalten.
Ja, das ist natürlich, wenn das wahr ist und wenn das irgendwie skaliert,
dann könnte das alles nochmal einen neuen Spin kriegen,
weil derzeit sind ja diese Fiber Optic Drones quasi die Antwort auf diesen Krieg
im elektromagnetischen Spektrum und diese ganzen Jammer Systeme,
die mehr oder weniger den normalen Funkbetrieb der Drohnen eingeschränkt oder
teilweise auch unmöglich gemacht haben.
Das wurde ja dann eben mit diesen Glasfaserdrohnen umgangen,
die hinten so einen dicken Tank drauf haben und während die Dinger halt fliegen,
legen sie halt quasi hinter sich einfach diese Glasfaser auf die Erde.
Aber wenn man, und wir hatten auch schon mal diesen Fall, dass sie so drehenden
Stacheldraht irgendwo installiert haben mit Motoren, um die dann klein zu machen.
Aber wenn sie jetzt in der Lage sind, quasi mit so einem Laser,
mit einer großen Leistung über den Boden rüber zu gehen und dann einfach diese
optischen Leitungen zu verbrennen, verschmelzen.
Sodass sie nicht mehr ordentlich oder gar nicht mehr kommunizieren können,
dann könnte das nochmal ganz interessant werden.
Also es ist das Prinzip, dass quasi die Glasfaser angegriffen wird mit dem Laser oder die Drohne.
Ja, so habe ich das verstanden.
Die Glasfaser landet ja quasi beim Fliegen auf dem Boden und du hast ja überall
mittlerweile diese ganzen Spinnweben von diesen Glasfasern.
Aber wenn du halt eine Drohnenaktivität siehst in deiner Nähe,
dann brauchst du ja quasi nur entlang der Flugbahn irgendwo auf dem Boden zu
gehen, weil da liegt dann...
Das rum. Und es muss ja nur irgendwo gekappt werden und es reicht ja auch eine einzige Trennung aus.
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das funktioniert, auch wenn ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig Ahnung habe, wie fett so ein Laser sein muss,
damit der auf welche Distanz da wirklich so eine Glasfaser nennenswert beschädigen kann.
Fett also sicherlich nicht händelt.
Das muss schon ein ziemlicher Apparat sein. Na ja, mal gucken.
Gut, damit kommen wir zu unserem zweiten und damit auch dem Hauptteil dieser
Sendung und zwar der Krieg der USA und Israel gegen den Iran.
Müssen wir behandeln, weil irgendwie hängt ja alles zusammen und nachdem wir
uns schon zu Venezuela so geäußert haben, dachten wir, müssen wir hier vielleicht
auch mal so unsere Gedanken fallen lassen.
Nicht nur das, sondern das Ganze ist halt fast noch im Moment eher beunruhigender
als der Ukraine-Krieg oder mindestens genauso beunruhigend mit potenziell katastrophalen
Folgen und natürlich einfach nur, um selber nicht verrückt zu werden.
So habe ich zumindest seit Dero losgebrochen,
ist doch wieder ein verstärkter mit Doomscrolling dem entgegenzuwirken versucht
und mir natürlich ein Bild zu machen, was passiert da wirklich.
Also sozusagen das Übliche, weil wir kriegen natürlich ein verzerrtes Bild.
Also beide Seiten versuchen natürlich, oder verschiedene Seiten versuchen jetzt
auch die Informationen,
die in ihrem Interesse sind, rauszubringen und andere zu unterdrücken oder auch.
Also es ist viel Propaganda auch unterwegs und dann ist es auch eine Gegend,
wo man jetzt in der Regel oder wo viele Leute einfach nicht so genau hingucken.
Und es ist auch eine ganze Weile her, jetzt seit die USA mit so einer Intensität
wieder in den Krieg eingestiegen sind.
Und ich meine, es war halt das Houthi-Bombardement, von dem man aber auch nicht
so viel mitgekriegt hat, so einen Monat lang.
Das war ja im letzten Jahr noch eine Sache, das war vielleicht die größte Aktion.
Ja, aber das, was da jetzt vor sich geht, das ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen neu.
Und das hat man sich in den letzten 40 Jahren einfach nicht getraut.
Zu tun, was jetzt passiert.
Ja, und es ist auch ein bisschen unklar, was so der Auslöser war.
Es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob Israel durch die Erfolge der letzten
Jahre und vielleicht auch durch diese 12-Tages-Bombardement im Dezember im Iran,
und die Tatsache, dass er quasi Trump dazu gebracht hat, da seine bunkerbrechenden
Waffen da auf diesen mutmaßlichen Atomstandort abzuwerfen,
so ein bisschen dazu verleitet hat, jetzt auch noch irgendwie den letzten seiner
feuchten Träume umzusetzen.
Ja, meiner Meinung nach hat der Erfolg der Special Maduro Operation in Venezuela
da doch stark dazu beigetragen,
weil das ist einfach nur ganz menschlich.
Nicht nur menschlich, sondern irgendwie alle Tiere, die meisten Tiere funktionieren so.
Wenn man in einem Kampf gewinnt, dann geht man mehr und härter und länger und
eher in den nächsten Kampf hinein.
Und wenn man eins auf die Nase kriegt, wird man halt vorsichtiger.
Ich meine, es ist einfach nur natürlich und insofern war der Erfolg in Venezuela
hat sicherlich die Bereitschaft erhöht.
Also für die USA und in Israel, Venezuela war jetzt für Israel ja kein Thema
und letztlich war es wohl so, dass diese,
Entscheidungen jetzt mit dem Krieg anzufangen, also das wissen wir natürlich
jetzt nicht, aber es ist so die Tatsache,
dass sie ja dann an einem Vormittag mit dem Krieg begonnen haben,
wo man normalerweise ja den Schutz der Nacht nutzt und das Ganze ja quasi mit
dem Attentat oder dem Angriff.
Ein Enthauptungsschlag.
Ja, ein Enthauptungsschlag auf den Kamenei und im Prinzip die gesamte militärische
und politische Führungsriege des Irans begonnen hat,
macht halt so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als hätte man dann das so zum Anlass
genommen einfach loszulegen, ohne wirklich vorbereitet zu sein und schon gar
nicht ausreichend alle Konsequenzen bedacht zu haben,
was das jetzt so nach sich zieht.
Und aus der Perspektive Israels ist halt immer so dieses, umso schwächer der
Iran ist, umso besser für uns.
Perspektive von Trump, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr, was ich sagen soll.
Der ist einfach führungslos und hat eigentlich keinen Plan, sondern reagiert
einfach nur noch und lässt sich im Prinzip irgendwas einreden.
Also Israel soll seit Jahrzehnten dieselbe Nummer mit jedem amerikanischen Präsidenten abgezogen haben.
Also bei Obama ist es verbirgt, dass wohl auch damals, glaube ich,
auch Netanyahu auf Obama zugegangen ist und gesagt hat, so, das geht jetzt so nicht weiter.
Wir greifen jetzt den Iran an und die werden dann zurückschlagen.
Also lasst es uns lieber dann gleich zusammen losschlagen.
Und Obama hat dann gesagt, nö, wir gehen da nicht mit rein und lasst das mal
schön sein, weil jetzt haben wir keinen Bock drauf. so.
Aber versucht haben sie es wie gesagt, also.
Wenn wir zu Standardmaschen und bei Trump hat es halt einfach funktioniert,
weil gerade richtige Zeit und aber vor allem auch jemanden, der eben offenbar
leicht manipulierbar ist.
Und Netanjahu scheint perfekt zu sein, was so Trump-Manipulieren angeht.
Die haben ja auch so ein bisschen gemeinsame Vergangenheit und haben ja auch
ein bisschen gemeinsame Erfahrungen mit dem Gerichtssystem ihrer Länder.
Beide wegen irgendwelcher kriminellen
Aktivitäten, Korruption und anderen Dingen unter Anklage und so.
Also von daher weiß Netanjahu auch wie Trump tickt und nur ist Netanjahu wahrscheinlich
einfach mal deutlich schlauer und nicht so Matsche in der Birne wie Trump,
weil das mittlerweile zu sein scheint.
Also was dann passiert, Iran und USA haben gemeinsam angegriffen,
Militärbasen, Waffendepots, Kommandozentralen, alles mögliche.
Dann hat aber der Iran auch sofort reagiert, was man erstmal so erwartet hätte,
also mit Angriffen auf Israel,
aber auch mit Angriffen auf die Standorte der Amerikaner, die im Golf ja zahlreich sind.
Also nahezu in jedem dieser Golfstaaten haben die Amerikaner irgendeine Basis
und die ist ja so vom Iran gar nicht so weit weg und sie haben dann halt mit
Raketen dort angegriffen,
also mit ihren ballistischen Raketen. Da haben die Amerikaner bzw.
Auch die Golfstaaten ja durchaus auch mit dem Patriot-System eine gute Reaktion gezeigt bzw.
Haben halt einfach das richtige Material und auch die Vorräte und es wurde glaube
ich in dieser ganzen Zeit, über die wir jetzt sprechen,
angeblich mehr Patriot-Raketen dort zum Einsatz gebracht, als bisher komplett
in der Ukraine zum Einsatz gebracht wurde.
Das halte ich mal für eine krasse Zahl.
Allerdings, naja, womit sie halt nicht so richtig gerechnet haben oder sich
nicht ausreichend darauf vorbereitet haben,
ist, dass der Iran auch mit ihren Schahits ankommt, die sich ja nun in den letzten
zwei Jahren in der Ukraine als einen echten Fluch entwickelt haben.
Stellt sich raus, Amerikaner haben gegen die Schaheds, genauso wie ihre Golfpartner,
gar nichts so richtig in der Hand.
Und die Dinger könnten zwar hier und da abgeschossen werden von Flugzeugen,
von Patriots, aber auch nicht alle.
Und so ist dann doch einiges auch zu Schaden gekommen.
Vor allem haben die Iraner es auf die Funkanlagen der Amerikaner angesehen,
Satellitensysteme, Funkschlüsseln aller Art, Radome. Da gab es ja diverse Bilder
zu sehen, aber eben auch Angriffe auf Standorte.
Da sind ja dann auch die ersten Amerikaner ums Leben gekommen,
weil sie da halt so einen Standort hatten, der halt überhaupt gar nicht von
Luftabwehr beschützt war, wie es aussieht.
Das waren dann so die ersten sieben oder acht Toten, die die Amerikaner jetzt
in diesem Krieg haben erleiden müssen. Ja, das war ja auch.
Ja, also am ersten Tag oder in den ersten 48 Stunden wurden erstmal massiv Waffen ausgetauscht.
Also das waren auch die größten Wellen an Raketen und Drohnen,
die der Iran losgeschickt hat.
Also wahrscheinlich zusammen irgendwie über 1000 Geschosse,
also Raketen und Drohnen zusammengenommen, die da ersten zwei Tagen losgeflogen sind.
Und das ging dann zwar einerseits runter, so was jetzt die Zahl von Raketen und Drohnen angeht,
die der Iran verschossen hat, während
er aber dann noch mehr Ziele angegriffen hat oder höherwertigere Ziele und sich
zwar auch hauptsächlich auf militärische Ziele konzentriert hat, muss man sagen,
aber dann irgendwann auch angefangen hat,
definitiv Raketen, also vor allem auf Israel dann abzuschießen,
die dann mit Cluster-Munition gefüllt waren und.
Die dann schon, ich sag mal, wo dann 40, 50 Sprengkörper verteilt über einen
Quadratkilometer oder so runtergehen, die alle so Sprengkraft, ja,
von fünf bis zehn Handgranaten haben, so ungefähr vergleichen,
also schon tödlich sind, wenn du da in einem Umkreis von zehn Metern oder so
dich aufhältst Und davon dann eben eine ganze Menge.
Und ja, am Ende hat der Iran ja praktisch auf die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
ungefähr 20 Prozent seiner Raketen verschossen.
Auf den Oman auch 20 Prozent, Iran auch ungefähr, aber ein bisschen weniger,
so 220 Sprengköpfe, Kuwait, Bahrain, Katar, Jordanien.
Irak, Saudi-Arabien und das ist noch nicht die vollständige Liste.
Also drei Drohnen sind auch nach Aserbaidschan reingegangen,
von denen eine dann in einem Park oder so gelandet sind und die Türkei mittlerweile
wurde auch ein paar Mal angegriffen.
Zypern wurde auch angegriffen, so vom Libanon aus allerdings, nicht vom Iran, ja.
Also insofern hat sich das ganz gut ausgeweitet.
Und insbesondere, wenn man jetzt so Flightracker rausholt und sich anguckt.
Der Verkehr drängt sich da jetzt, also der Luftverkehr, einmal zwischen der
Gegend, die aufgrund des Ukraine-Kriegs gesperrt wurde.
Und jetzt unten die Gegend, im Prinzip, ja, Iran, aber auch Irak,
Israel, diese Syrien, ist der Luftraum auch leer und da quetschen sich dann
unten dann die Flugzeuge.
Also fehlt nicht mehr viel.
Und ganz oben ist natürlich Russland auch mit seiner Nicht-Durchflugzone und
fehlt eigentlich nur noch ein bisschen ein weiterer regionaler Konflikt dort.
Und wir haben da von, weiß nicht, fast vom Äquator bis zum Nordpol eine No-Fly-Zone,
wo dann alle irgendwie ziemlich weit, alle Flugzeuge ziemlich weit nach Süden
runter müssen, wenn sie dann diese Nord-Süd-Linie überqueren wollen.
Und ja...
Am Anfang haben sich über beide Seiten mehr auf militärische Ziele fokussiert und dann am 7.
März hat dann Israel in Teheran ein großes Öldepot und Raffineriekomplex angegriffen.
Und das hat halt apokalyptische Bilder, Zeug mit brennendem Öl,
was durch die Straßen fließt und schwarzem Regen und ja, ein riesen Inferno.
Und diese Bilder dann haben dazu geführt, dass in kürzester Zeit der Ölpreis
auf 125 Dollar pro Barrel hoch schoss.
Ich denke, das war hauptsächlich diesen Bildern zu schulden,
weil jetzt befürchtet wurde, dass wenn der Iran jetzt gleichermaßen zurückschlägt,
dass das jetzt eskaliert.
Die USA waren wohl auch nicht so happy, was Israel da getan hat und von dem Fallout.
Und Trump war dann gezwungen oder hat dann einfach behauptet,
der Krieg ist jetzt schon fast zu Ende.
Worauf der Ölpreis erst mal gefallen ist, wieder auf die 80, 85er Region.
Und hat aber wohl dann auch Israel verboten, weitere Raffinerien zu bombardieren.
Und der Iran auch behauptet, dass in den letzten Tagen sich die Bombardements
tatsächlich doch stark auf,
ja praktisch nur auf militärische Ziele konzentriert hätten.
Im Iran.
Im Iran, ja. Also das, was die Amerikaner und Israelis jetzt angreifen,
seien aus iranischer Sicht alles militärische Ziele.
Was, wenn das stimmt, dafür spricht, dass dann auch USA gesehen hat,
Trump gesehen hat, wir können da jetzt die Ölinfrastruktur nicht so weiter angreifen.
Aber was der Iran jetzt auch klar gemacht hat, ist, dass er.
Ich will, dass Schiffe ohne Autorisierung aus dem Golf rausfahren,
also durch die Straße von Hormuz fahren.
Sagen, wenn ihr um Erlaubnis fragt, also Schiffe, die bei uns um Erlaubnis fragen,
lassen wir potenziell durch.
Es sei denn, sie gehören irgendwie zu Ländern, die uns angreifen,
aber Länder, die uns freundlich gesinnt sind, die dürfen halt auch durchfahren.
Dann war es auch jetzt zu der perversen Situation, dass halt tatsächlich der
Iran weiterhin Öl exportiert, vor allem nach China.
Aber auch Wissen und Erlaubnis der USA, weil natürlich könnten sie es unterbinden, wenn sie es wollten.
Aber erstens wäre dann China wahrscheinlich deutlich noch ungehaltener.
Also das könnte dann tatsächlich zu einem massiven Konflikt mit China führen.
Aber auch, wobei China hat auch große Reserven, aber auch Japan und Südkorea und vor allem Taiwan.
Taiwan hat irgendwie Ölreserven für neun Tage oder so.
Das heißt, und deren Kraftwerke und deren Chipproduktion hängt halt davon ab.
Also das ist auch dünne. Das heißt, effektiv ist der Golf jetzt für...
Für westliche Schiffe gesperrt und für iranische und russische und chinesische
Schiffe ist er weiter offen.
Und um das eben auch zu enforcen, haben dann jetzt in den letzten Tagen.
Hat der Iran dann vermehrt Schiffe angegriffen, die versucht haben, da durchzufahren.
Also Trump hat irgendwann gesagt, hier, stellt euch nicht so an,
ist alles sicher, habt mal ein bisschen Eier in der Hose und fahrt da jetzt
gefälligst durch. Das haben auch so viele.
Ich habe sechs oder sieben Schiffe vorgestern dann versucht und zwei davon,
drei davon sind halt angegriffen worden.
Und ja, sehr spektakulär dann auch ein Öltanker, ein beladener Öltanker,
wobei der halt von hinten angegriffen wurde mit einer Seedrohne.
Also dasselbe, wo dieselbe Klasse von Waffen,
mit denen die Ukraine das Schwarze Meer von russischen Kampfschiffen gesäubert hat,
die Art von Waffen kam da zum Einsatz.
Und da sind die quasi von hinten, da wo die Schraube und das Ruder sitzt,
hinten reingefahren und haben ein Loch gesprengt, das man jetzt in den Maschinenraum
reingucken kann von außen.
Aber Öl scheint nicht ausgetreten zu sein.
Das wäre ja nun auch nicht im Interesse des Iran. Aber insofern ist das schon
ein sehr riskantes Geschäft, was sie da fahren.
Ich meine, die Aussage, die Straße sei gesperrt, das war ja auch erstmal nur so eine Aussage.
Es gab wohl auch diverse Schiffe, die einfach ihre Transponder abgeschaltet
haben und irgendwie so Augen zu und durch.
Ein Hauptgrund am Anfang, ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wie das jetzt ist,
dass viele ja auch ohne die Ankündigung, dass jetzt die Straße gesperrt sei,
die Straße von Hermos meine ich.
Da nicht mehr durchgefahren sind, weil die Versicherungen halt nicht mitgezogen haben.
Also bei den Schifffahrtsversicherungen ist es halt so, man darf halt eigentlich
ein Schiff nicht über die Weltmeere fahren, wenn man nicht versichert ist.
Und die Versicherung, die Preise hängen natürlich davon ab, wie groß ist dein
Schiff, aber vor allem auch, wie groß ist die Gefahr.
Und da gibt es so drei Stufen und ja, da ist jetzt definitiv die maximale Stufe
und es war jetzt nicht unbedingt geregelt.
Das heißt, viele müssen sich jetzt auch erstmal mit den Versicherungen unterhalten.
Dann kam ja Trump und meinte so, ja, Versicherung, kein Problem,
das übernehmen wir überhaupt und Geleitschiffe und so. Ich meine,
die werden einen Teufel tun und ihre Kriegsschiffe jetzt direkt 20 Kilometer
vor der Küste von Iran langfahren lassen.
Ich meine, das ist ein gefundenes Fressen für den Iran. Also das wird halt nicht stattfinden.
Und dementsprechend haben sich halt viele jetzt dazu entschieden, hier nicht...
Durchzufahren und erstmal zu parken. Und es betrifft halt jetzt,
ich meine man muss ja nochmal klar machen, wer eigentlich jetzt im Golf in diesem
inneren Teil da so angesiedelt ist.
Also wir haben, wenn man auf diese Region drauf schaut, natürlich den großen
Landkörper Saudi-Arabiens.
Das ist sozusagen von diesem Persischen Golf im Großteil so die linke Seite,
die dem Iran so gegenüber liegt.
Da ist dann auch noch diese Insel von Bahrain, da
ist noch diese Halbinsel von Katar und oben an der Grenze zum Irak liegt noch
Kuwait und das sind natürlich alles Öl- und Erdgas exportierende Staaten und
auch die Saudi-Arabia haben dort eben ihre Haupthäfen.
Dann im Süden des Persischen Golfs, also noch vor der Straße von Hormuz,
also vor im Sinne von bevor es raus geht zum Golf von Oman.
Da sitzen die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate, also Abu Dhabi,
Dubai und auch die sind natürlich jetzt hier betroffen.
Das heißt, all diese Nationen können jetzt über den Golf nichts mehr rausliefern.
Wie es mit dem Irak ist, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig.
Die halten sich ja raus, soweit ich weiß.
Also es gibt natürlich auch Basen der Amerikaner auf irakischem Staatsgebiet,
aber das ist ja dann eher in Kurdistan.
Also keine Ahnung, welche Rolle der Irak spielt, speziell im Süden,
so Basra und so, wo die ganzen Ölproduktionen sind und die Häfen der Iraker, da...
Da gibt es ja eine Mehrheit der Schiiten, die ja eigentlich mit dem Iran theoretisch
eher in Allianz sind. Aber über den Bereich weiß ich nichts.
Im neuen irakischen Parlament wurde auch bereits skandiert irgendwie Tod für Amerika.
Genau, ist die Stimmung jetzt nicht so super.
Vielleicht, um sich das noch ein bisschen besser vorzustellen,
ist wahrscheinlich da dieser,
Und diese Straße von Hormuz ist so jetzt um die 30 Kilometer breit und die meisten 20 Kilometer.
Das heißt, man kann da rüber gucken bei normalem Wetter, wenn jetzt nicht gerade
Nebel ist oder so, kann man halt jedes Schiff, was da durchfährt, vom Ufer aus sehen.
So, das heißt, da ist jetzt nichts auch so richtig mit heimlich durchfahren
normalerweise, außer vielleicht bei schlechtem Wetter oder so.
Also 30 Kilometer ist, glaube ich, der schiffbare Bereich. Die Landmassen sind
schon noch mal ein bisschen weiter, so ungefähr 50 Kilometer,
je nachdem, wo man da jetzt den Bogen spannt.
Ja, aber vielleicht so, ja, Bodensee wahrscheinlich, würde ich mal schätzen.
So Dimensionen, also zumindest, ja.
Auf jeden Fall eng in den Dimensionen. Also Kuwait, Saudi-Arabien,
Bahrain, Katar, VAE, das sind so die unmittelbar betroffenen Länder.
Wenn man dann durch die Straße von Humus durch ist, dann ist man ja im Golf,
dann ist man nicht mal im persischen Golf, sondern im Golf von Oman,
weil dort halt Oman grenzt.
Oman ist ja so ein Land, über das relativ wenig geredet wird.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass Oman sich eigentlich immer aus allem so ein bisschen raushält.
Oman ist auch eines der Länder, die eigentlich immer versucht haben,
zwischen den Golfanrainern und dem Iran zu vermitteln.
Oman hält ja sowieso sein Profil sehr flach, ist auch ölexportierend,
hat aber an der Gesamtproduktion nur einen sehr geringen Anteil,
aber ist natürlich von dieser Blockade auch nicht betroffen.
Trotzdem hat, und das hat mich auch überrascht, gab es einen Angriff der Iraner
auf Oman, aber das hat sich glaube ich nicht so wiederholt.
Aber die haben Oman massiv mit irgendwie 260 ballistischen Raketen angegriffen.
Echt, so viele?
Ja.
Oh, okay, das überrascht mich jetzt.
Also ganz oben gleiche Zahl wie die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate und mehr
als nach Israel, wobei sie für Israel halt die großen brauchen.
Und dann sind wir so um die 220 ballistische Raketen auf Israel abgefeuert.
Und dann jeweils so Kuwait, Bahrain und Katar, also Kuwait 180 und Bahrain,
Katar, so um die 100, Jordanien 80,
Irak ungefähr 20 und nur eine Handvoll auf Saudi-Arabien.
Aber das hat jetzt ein bisschen, also jetzt haben sie ein bisschen mehr auch
auf Saudi-Arabien wohl noch abgefeuert.
Und um jetzt mal zum Verlauf, was halt gerade jetzt in den letzten ein,
zwei Tagen alles passiert ist,
dass es jetzt noch weitere verletzte US-Soldaten in Erbil und Bagdad gegeben
hat, also beides im Irak.
Dann wurden sechs französische Soldaten und einer, glaube ich,
ist jetzt getötet worden, auch im Irak, in Kurdistan.
Die Franzosen haben da so eine gemeinsame Basis mit den Peschmergern.
Und es ist wohl ohne Feindeinwirkung ein KC-135-Tankflugzeug über dem Irak auch
noch abgestürzt und vermutlich sind die sechs Besatzungsmitglieder dabei ums Leben gekommen.
Offiziell gelten sie noch als vermisst, aber die haben halt keine Schleudersitze
oder Fallschirme an Bord, soweit ich weiß.
Und ja, also ist da dann jetzt die Zahl der amerikanischen Toten,
hat sich jetzt noch mal fast verdoppelt durch diesen Unfall.
Wobei es auch irgendwelche Organisationen gibt, die claimen,
dass sie da irgendwie ihre Hände drin gehabt hätten.
Aber offiziell, ja, war es ohne Fremdeinwirkung.
Ja, und...
Wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt dann so aktuell in der Situation,
ja vor allem Konzentration von beiden Seiten auf militärische Ziele,
wobei der Iran halt nicht ganz so präzise Waffen hat und es deswegen eben auch
dann öfter zu Einschlägen kommt in Zivilinfrastruktur.
Oder sagen dann, ja, in diesem Hotel haben sie jetzt amerikanische Soldaten aufgehalten.
Deswegen haben wir dieses Hotel jetzt ins Visier genommen.
Und ja, plus bei Israel, so da haben sie halt, wie gesagt, mit Clusterbomben geschossen.
Und das gilt halt allgemein als, ja, unangemessen typischerweise.
Also wenn du jetzt über eine Militärbasis jetzt abfeuerst, ja, dann ist das legitim.
Aber die haben sich halt wohl teilweise eben mitten in Israel,
so über dem Stadtgebiet geöffnet und massiv Schäden verursacht.
Und es gibt eben auch eine internationale Konvention,
diese Waffen komplett zu bannen, aus eben anderen Gründen, oder weil eben viele
von diesen Clusterbomben dann liegen bleiben und Gefahr für Zivilbevölkerung darstellen.
Aber weder die USA, noch Israel, noch Iran sind dieser beigetreten.
Und nicht nur das, viele sind jetzt auch ausgetreten, also unter anderem die
Ukraine, die baltischen Staaten, also das hat keine Zukunft an der Stelle.
Das habe ich zu der Situation, ja und also zum,
Zur Straße jetzt von Humus, also bevor die Feindseligkeiten begonnen haben,
sind da ungefähr 100 Schiffe durchgefahren pro Tag.
Das Maximum, was seitdem durchgegangen ist, waren jetzt sechs Schiffe,
die es versucht haben, ich glaube vorgestern und das ist nicht so gut gegangen.
Und jetzt ist es offiziell, also die offiziellen Zählungen so,
ein, zwei Schiffe fahren da im Moment durch.
Und ja, das heißt, die entscheidende Frage jetzt ist, wann geht die Straße wieder auf?
So, und ja, du hattest schon gesagt, Versicherung, das Versicherungsproblem ist jetzt gelöst.
Also interessant ist auch die Versicherer. Die Großen, die gehören alle den Rädern im Prinzip.
Das heißt, es ist sozusagen die Schifffahrtsindustrie unter sich,
weswegen die da auch, wenn die die Raten erhöhen,
Versicherungsraten für Risikogebiete und so, müssen die da schon vorher genau
rechnen und sich dann eben auch einigen und sich dann rückversichern.
Also das erfordert eine ganze Menge an Organisationen, die dann eben den Versicherungsschutz
bereitstellen müssen. Aber das ist jetzt nicht das Problem.
Das Problem, was jetzt eben da ist, ist, sie haben es halt jetzt versucht.
Iran hat halt erfolgreich Schiffe angegriffen. Und jetzt halt,
ja, also die Räder wollen natürlich jetzt auch, selbst wenn die Schiffe versichert
sind, haben jetzt keinen Bock, Schiffe zu verlieren oder Groß zu verlieren oder
eben dann hohe Versicherungssummen auszuzahlen.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn dann eine Ölpest jetzt entsteht, kann da locker so eine
Milliarde oder zwei Milliarden an Schaden entstehen.
Und hat natürlich keiner Bock drauf, das zu bezahlen.
Ja, also das ist im Moment jetzt die Situation und die Frage ist so,
wie kann das denn jetzt weitergehen und wie wird das wahrscheinlich weitergehen
und dazu natürlich die große Frage,
was haben denn die beiden Seiten, die sich jetzt gegenüberstehen in militärischen
Fähigkeiten noch und wie lange können beide Seiten das irgendwie durchhalten?
Und das Interessanteste am Iran ist der Zoo an ballistischen Raketen,
den der Iran so entwickelt hat über die letzten Jahrzehnte.
Ich glaube, kein Land auf der Welt hat so viele verschiedene ballistische Raketen
und auch so viele ballistische Raketen in der Menge einfach so Anzahl wie der der Iran.
Da haben sie sich massiv drauf fokussiert und man geht davon aus,
speziell, dass sie zwischen 2000 und 3000 ballistische Raketen vor Kriegsbeginn hatten.
Und es ist aber nicht ausgeschlossen, dass sie auch doppelt so viele haben.
So, das weiß man einfach nicht genau.
Man weiß, dass Sie über 1200 davon,
jetzt gestartet haben und hunderte am Boden zerstört sind und dass am wahrscheinlichsten
irgendwie noch 500 bis 1000 ballistische Raketen übrig sind,
können aber auch deutlich mehr sein.
Wir wissen es nicht. Könnte auch sein, dass sie 2.000 oder 3.000 ballistische
Raketen noch übrig haben.
Bei den Schahit-Drohnen haben sie vermutlich mehr.
Man weiß es nicht. Schätzungen gehen davon aus, dass sie mindestens 10.000 davon haben.
Aber Zahlen gehen auch bis zu 30.000 Schahits, die sie noch irgendwo gebunkert
haben. so in die Gegend bewegt sich das. Und,
Das Irre ist, also mit diesen ballistischen Raketen,
erstmal werden sie wahrscheinlich ihr etwas älteres Arsenal hauptsächlich abgefeuert haben,
mit noch den einfacheren Raketen.
Aber sie haben eben auch recht moderne oder advanced ballistische Raketen und
die speziell auch dafür designt sind, jetzt Luftabwehr,
also sowas wie die PAK-3 möglichst zu umfliegen.
Also PAK-3 ist die Abwehrrakete des Patriot-Systems oder eine der?
Genau, um Patriot speziell oder generell Luftabwehrraketen auszuweichen und
was eben die neueren Systeme jetzt können oder ja eigentlich,
was auch zum Beispiel Attackums von jetzt PRISM, also das sind die amerikanischen,
eigentlich fast die einzigen amerikanischen ballistischen Raketen angeht,
ist, dass früher, also ältere ballistische Raketen fliegen immer auch eine ballistische
Flugbahn, also eine Parabel im Prinzip,
fliegen halt hoch und kommen dann auf einer relativ vorhersehbaren Flugbahn runter.
Während die modernen ballistischen Raketen haben halt die Möglichkeit,
dann beim Wiedereintritt so zu steuern.
Aber die fliegen auch, die erreichen
ihren Höhepunkt ihrer Flugbahn viel früher, gehen dann runter und.
Und gehen dann in, ich sag mal, mehr einen horizontalen Gleitflug über,
wo sie dann schwerer zu orten sind, weil sie dann niedriger reinkommen und können
dann eben diese Flugbahn auch variieren und die sind halt extrem schwierig abzufangen und ja.
Und diese Raketen teilweise tragen auch recht große Sprengköpfe,
je nachdem von 300 Kilo bis die größten bis zwei Tonnen, die sie haben,
aber davon haben sie wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so viele.
Aber sie haben dann zum Beispiel auch als vermutlich Einziger auf der Welt mit
der FAT-H1 eine Waffe, die benutzt,
die hat ein Raketentriebwerk,
was im Endanflug noch aktiviert wird, was eigentlich nur dazu da ist,
den Reibungswiderstand beim Wiedereintritt zu neutralisieren.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass die Flugzeit durch die Atmosphäre kürzer ist und
die Dinger mit ungefähr Mach 10 einschlagen.
So, weil sie halt dann noch die letzten 5 bis 10 Sekunden oder so ein,
ja, wie gesagt, ein Triebwerk haben, was den Luftwiderstand einfach reduziert,
indem sie Gase nach hinten ausstoßen.
Und ja, das hat halt verschiedene Effekte. Und ja, die sind halt nur in wirklich
Ausnahmefällen, da muss man Glück haben, um die abzufangen.
Was jetzt die gemeldeten Abfangraten auch angeht, halte ich die für zu hoch.
Also es wurde dann behauptet, dass irgendwie bis zu 90 Prozent abgeschossen
wurden von den ballistischen Raketen.
Die Wahrheit ist wahrscheinlich umgekehrt, ist wahrscheinlich eher 10 Prozent abgeschossen worden.
So, weil ich meine...
Man sagt, ja, und alte ballistische Raketen eher noch, aber die modernen haben
eigentlich einstellige Prozentzahlen von Abfangraten.
Und was natürlich gemacht wird, ist,
wenn du da jetzt, du schief verschießt mindestens zwei davon,
aber um auf diese Raten zu kommen,
müsste man fünf bis zehn Abfangraketen auf jede anfliegende Rakete kommen,
um auf irgendwie 80 oder 90 Prozent zu kommen.
Also das halte ich für einfach nicht realistisch.
Also es gibt nichts, auch die Patriot kann da keine Sicherheit wirklich schaffen.
Dann...
Wie gesagt, und es wurden eben über 1.000,
also 1.200, mittlerweile wahrscheinlich 1.300 von diesen Raketen abgefeuert
und vermutlich mindestens noch mal so viel, wie sie verschossen haben, kommt und sie sparen.
Angeblich bereiten sie sich darauf vor, bis zu den Mittagnenwahlen durchzuhalten,
und rationieren daher ihr Arsenal und eben es auch anzunehmen,
dass sie so die besseren Waffen besser geschützt haben, die moderneren,
und dass es eher schwieriger werden wird,
die jetzt abzufangen.
Lange Zeit hat man sich auch gefragt, was ist mit den Cruise Missiles,
die der Iran hat, weil die wurden kaum gesehen, aber jetzt hat der Iran auch
angefangen mit Cruise Missiles, also Prinzip Tomahawk, ähnliche Systeme, die sie haben,
werden nicht so viele davon haben, ein paar hundert, aber nichtsdestotrotz.
Und ja, kommen die Dinger auch ins Ziel und sind wohl teilweise auch recht modern.
Interessanterweise, ja, die Long-Range Drohnen basieren auf einer Familie von,
ja, ist eine Familie von sowjetischen KH-55, die sie in den frühen 2000er Jahren
von der Ukraine gekauft haben.
Es war aber noch unter, ja, als die Ukraine noch irgendwie ein treuer Vasall
Russlands war und haben dann unter anderem auch jetzt neue Drohnen, paar W,
so Latest Shit aus 2032, die wahrscheinlich so mit Storm Shadow oder so vergleichbar
sein dürften von den Features.
Ja, und.
Die USA umgekehrt, wenn wir jetzt bei ballistischen Raketen erstmal bleiben,
so hat tatsächlich jetzt Attack Hams und Prism verschossen mit HIMARS.
Ungefähr so 100 Stück in der Größenordnung.
Und ja, das ist das, was da jetzt an Waffen zum Einsatz kommt gerade.
Und von der US-Seite ist der Großteil der Angriffe bisher mit Abstandswaffen erfolgt.
Also es gibt Abstandswaffen oder Stand-off-Weapons,
wie es so heißt, sind Waffen, die man aus größerer Entfernung abfeuern kann,
so wie Cruise Missiles und Raketen im Wesentlichen,
entweder Boden- oder auch Luftgestartete.
Und Abstandswaffen sind eben mit, aber auch die teuersten so.
Und dann gibt es eben die Stand-In-Weapons, was im Wesentlichen Bomben oder
Gleitbomben sind oder die,
wo du mit dem Flugzeug rein musst und die dann im Prinzip über dem Ziel oder
nahe dem Ziel abwerfen musst.
Und diese Phase hat erst vor ein paar Tagen begonnen,
dass sich die USA trauen, jetzt auch in Israel reinzugehen und mehr mit Bomben zuzumachen,
weil Preisunterschied ist da oft 10 zu 1 oder so, was jetzt die Wirkung ist.
Und ich hatte recht früh am dritten oder vierten Tag, dass die USA angeblich
schon mit B-52-Bombern auch angreifen.
Und da dachte ich mir, na gut, wenn du mit so einer alten B-52 jetzt ins Kriegsgebiet
fährst, dann müssen wir tatsächlich volle Luftüberlegenheit haben.
Tatsächlich hat die B-52 aber auch im Wesentlichen Abstandswaffen einfach nur
verwendet von weit außerhalb des iranischen Luftraums und in der Welt.
Mit den Abstandswaffen, wie gesagt, die Rate war weiterhin sehr hoch.
Wo man entweder sagen muss, entweder haben die USA zu viel oder verschwenden
einfach viel zu viele von den teuren Abstandswaffen.
Oder sie rauen sich nicht wirklich rein. Also diese absolute Luftüberlegenheit,
der trauen sie dann möglicherweise doch nicht.
Also wir finden uns irgendwo, also eins von beiden kann nur wahr sein.
Also entweder ist die Situation im Griff,
dann könnten sie eigentlich reinfliegen, aber sie benutzen trotzdem noch einen
sehr, sehr hohen Teil an teuren Abstandswaffen oder sie müssen es benutzen,
weil es doch irgendwie noch zu gefährlich ist,
zu tief in den iranischen Luftraum reinzugehen.
Ja und auch da geht ja nicht alles gut. Also gut ist ja sowieso nichts dran.
Was man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen muss ist ja dieser Angriff mit Tomahawk Missiles,
der unter anderem auch so eine Schule, so eine Mädchenschule im Iran getroffen
hat, wo angeblich sehr viele Kinder ums Leben gekommen sind, über 100 Jahre.
Es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob das hier so Bad Intelligence war,
weil das Gebäude quasi also nicht nur direkt an so einen Militärstandort angegrenzt
hat, sondern wohl früher auch mal Teil dessen war.
Und dementsprechend haben sie wahrscheinlich bei der Zielplanung dieses Gebäude
einfach mit reingenommen, aber nicht gewusst oder übersehen, wer auch immer,
dass es sich dabei eben mitnichten um ein militärisches Gebäude handelt und
dann dort eben auch eine Tomahawk reingeballert.
Ja, alte Daten. Was ich halt faszinierend finde, ist, dass auf der einen Seite
jetzt Pete Hexas, der amerikanische Vicks- oder Verteidigungsminister, je nachdem,
selber zeichnet sich ja als Vicks-Minister und hat ja irgendwie das Department
of Defense in Department of War umbenannt.
Aber in irrer Weise der.
Haben sie sich wieder getraut, das Ganze offiziell als Krieg zu bezeichnen,
obwohl sie sich dann dauernd verquatscht haben?
Und dann sieht man aber auch an dem Beispiel so das ganze Gerede von, ja,
wir keine dummen Regeln und wir haben eure Unterstützung und wir gehen da jetzt
mit maximaler Letalität rein.
Und ja, jetzt ist Schluss mit Lust.
Am Ende sieht man, naja, kannst da halt noch so viel daherreden,
wenn du dann trotzdem einfach eine Schule in die Luft sprengst und über 100 Kinder tötest,
dann kommt das einfach nicht gut an.
Ja, weder zu Hause noch im Rest der Welt.
Das heißt, diese Regeln der halbwegs zivilisierten Kriegsführung gelten halt,
ob die jemand entforst oder nicht.
Und das Ganze führt dann einfach auch nur dazu, dass der Widerstand in der Bevölkerung steigt.
Das wissen auch alle Historiker angefangen, von als die Nazis angefangen haben,
England zu bombardieren, stieg dann auch eher die Entschlossenheit in der Bevölkerung.
Und umgekehrt, als dann die Alliierten angefangen haben,
die Bevölkerung in Deutschland und Achsenmächte zu bombardieren,
hat das jetzt auch nicht dazu geführt,
dass irgendwie Leute gesagt haben, jetzt ist aber Schluss mit Krieg oder jetzt
haben wir keinen Bock mehr, sondern es hat auch einfach nur die Entschlossenheit gestärkt.
Und so ist es hier eben auch.
Ja, okay, das sind jetzt so diese ganzen Angriffswaffen, was ja jetzt sehr im
Fokus auch steht, sind ja die ganzen Verteidigungssysteme, beziehungsweise es
ist nicht vorhanden sein, selbiger.
Natürlich sind die ganzen US-Militärbasen mit einer ganzen Menge Abwehrsysteme
gerüstet, aber wie schon erwähnt,
gibt es Schwierigkeiten mit den Waffen, mit denen der Iran angreift,
jetzt hier auch wirklich gegenzuschlagen und vor allem ist das auch alles super teuer.
Ja, also was dort massiv zum Einsatz gekommen ist,
sind die richtig teuren Systeme, also Patriot vor allen Dingen, aber auch TARD,
die sind pro Rakete doppelt so teuer wie Patriot, die fliegen höher,
Terminal High Altitude Air Defense oder so.
Und die kosten irgendwie um die 10 Millionen pro Interceptor,
während Patriot man so eher um die 5 kriegt.
Wobei die Preise schwanken halt stark und die Preisschätzungen,
aber größenordnungsmäßig.
Und die Navy hat dann eben noch SM-3, Standard Missile 3. Das ist auch so vergleichbar
mit Patriot und Israel hat dann noch Arrow 2 und Arrow 3 und das sind alles so Raketen, die,
Fünf Millionen Aufwärtskosten im Prinzip.
Und davon zusammengenommen, ja, wurden mehr abgefeuert, also von den teuren
Raketen als jetzt Patriot-Systeme in der Ukraine,
weil Ukraine hat halt nur Patriot aus dieser Klasse von Waffen.
Denn Ukraine hat keinen Pfad.
Und wie gesagt, das Thema Abfangraten, also offiziell doppelt 98 Prozent,
aber über alles, aber das halte ich für übertrieben, das halte ich für massiv übertrieben.
Und ja, was jetzt gerade auch vorgestern durch die Presse ging,
vor allem in Südkorea, ist, dass dort Hart- und Patriot-Systeme abgebaut wurden.
So, da sind halt die Zeitungen gerade voll mit Bildern von ehemaligen Abfangpositionen
oder wo die Systeme stationiert waren und wie die halt eingepackt werden und jetzt in den Golf gehen.
Und dementsprechend ist jetzt in Südkorea halt die Bevölkerung auch mehr als
alarmiert, sondern auch ein bisschen pisst, so nach dem Motto, ey,
was soll denn das, ihr geht da rein und habt offenbar nicht genug darüber nachgedacht,
was denn passieren könnte.
Und jetzt zieht ihr hier unsere Raketenabwehr ab.
Ja, das hat ja dann auch dazu geführt, dass die Ukraine jetzt hier mit ins Spiel
gekommen ist bei der Luftabwehr und das ist eh ganz interessant.
Ja, denn erstmal hat die Ukraine sehr viel mehr Erfahrung in der Abwehr von Schahed-Drohnen,
die ja hier in zunehmendem Maße ein großes Problem darstellen und das nicht
nur Erfahrung und damit auch gut ausgebildete Leute und entsprechende Strategien,
sondern sie haben ja mit ihrer Reihe von Interceptor-Drohens,
also Sting und wie sie alle heißen, mittlerweile auch eine große Produktion am Start,
um eben entsprechende Verteidigungen vorzunehmen.
Also Interceptor-Drohnen sind diese etwas raketenartig geformten Quadrokopter,
die eben jederzeit vom Boden aus starten und aber auch wieder selbstständig
landen können, die also losgehen, wenn sie in irgendeiner Form aktiviert werden,
manuell oder automatisch, das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Also kommt eine Schahett geflogen, dann ist das Ding in der Nähe,
dann können die mit 300 Stundenkilometer hinter diesen Schahetts hinterher fliegen
und sie im Idealfall dann eben auch mit zu Fall bringen, indem sie dann eben
in der Nähe explodieren.
Wenn das nicht klappt oder keine Schahett zu sehen ist und das ein Fehlalarm
war, können die halt auch wieder landen und sich neu aufladen lassen und dann
sind sie für den nächsten Einsatz auch schon wieder da. Aber diese Technologie,
über die verfügt halt nur die Ukraine.
Entsprechend waren die Golfstaaten, die ja jetzt wirklich eine Menge Stress
haben, wie viel Stress wir da sehen, das werden wir gleich auch nochmal besprechen,
haben sich jetzt in der Ukraine schnell gemeldet, auch wohl die USA.
Und ja, Zelensky hat gesagt, ja okay, alles klar, dann helfen wir euch auch.
Zu welchen Konditionen das dann stattgefunden hat, das wissen wir natürlich
nicht, aber ich vermute mal,
hier dürfte es auch etwas Kompensation geben, sind ja unterschiedliche Sachen
da gerüchtet worden, ich meine, Geld wird auf jeden Fall fließen,
aber es kann halt auch gut sein, dass ein Deal gemacht wird mit,
Patriot-Raketenbeständen etc., wo es ja immer knapp ist bei der Ukraine.
Dass hier vielleicht ein Deal gemacht wird, weil die Golfstaaten halt ganz gute
Vorräte haben oder zumindest hatten.
Man weiß jetzt auch nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie viel noch da ist.
Aber mit diesen Interceptor-Drohnen, die können sie natürlich schnell an den
Start bringen und machen das wahrscheinlich auch überall.
Im Falle von VAE, also Abu Dhabi, ist es wohl sogar so,
dass schon eine Beteiligung an einem Rüstungsunternehmen, Und ich habe es jetzt
gerade vergessen, welches es ist, aber ich meine, dass es sich dabei auch um Firepoint handelt,
dass die halt so eine 30-prozentige Beteiligung jetzt gestartet haben.
Das war wohl schon vorher in Verhandlungen und ist jetzt schnell zu Ende gebracht worden.
Und ja, das könnte eben zu einer interessanten Dynamik führen,
dass also erstens die Ukraine hier wirklich ein bisschen der Retter der Infrastruktur
sein kann und es wird ja eine Menge Infrastruktur angegriffen,
nicht nur die militärischen Ziele,
sind ja auch schon Bomben in Entsalzungsanlagen zum Beispiel untergegangen,
es sind Hotels in Bahrain und in Dubai angegriffen worden,
das ist alles nicht gut und das können die sich nicht leisten, Und ja,
von daher ist die Ukraine jetzt hier ein Player und könnte unter Umständen auch
finanziell und auch politisch profitieren, weil natürlich jetzt die Golfstaaten
ein hohes Interesse daran haben, auch der Ukraine zu helfen,
wo sie vorher vielleicht so ein bisschen sich zurückgehalten haben.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher, inwieweit sie jetzt tatsächlich in den nächsten
Tagen oder Wochen dazu beitragen werden,
dass da Schahids abgefangen werden,
weil die trainieren halt jetzt dort wohl in drei verschiedenen Golfstaaten.
Also Selensky gesagt, drei Drohnenteams sind unterwegs, die halt dann jetzt
lokale Kräfte vor allen Dingen ausbilden sollen und so.
Das heißt, die trainieren es jetzt dort mit denen hauptsächlich.
Ja, es ist ja nicht nur Training, es sind ja auch die Sensorsysteme,
die sie aufgebaut haben.
Gut, die akustischen Systeme, weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt bei so einer Seerandlage
so hilfreich ist, weil du hast natürlich dann entsprechend keine Vorwarnzeit.
Von daher muss man die Strategie schon ändern, aber wir wissen auch nicht,
ob das ja sozusagen das Einzige ist.
Also hilfreich sein wird es
wahrscheinlich schon, aber eher mehr mittelfristig als jetzt kurzfristig.
Wobei dann natürlich auch wieder jetzt Pressemeldungen in den USA, dass die Ukraine vor,
sieben, acht Monaten oder so noch mal konkret angeboten haben soll,
diese Drohnentechnologie, diese Abwehrtechnologie mit den USA zusammen weiterzuentwickeln.
Und die USA hat dann gesagt, nö, brauchen wir nicht, haben wir kein Interesse dran.
Solche Aktionen kommen natürlich dann jetzt auch nicht gut an.
Lassen einen nicht als besonders weise oder vorausschauend aussehen.
Ja, kommen wir nochmal zur Strategie der USA, beziehungsweise The Lack Thereof.
Also man hat jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, dass es hier überhaupt eine Strategie
gibt oder wenn es eine gab, dass die besonders weit nach vorne geblickt hat.
Es macht auf mich den Eindruck, als ob sich sowohl Israel als auch die USA hier
in ein Manöver begeben haben.
Dass sie nicht gewinnen können. Also wenn man jetzt mal die öffentliche Diskussion
verfolgt, da wurde ja alles mögliche gesagt.
In den ersten Tagen, als Trump noch total im Kriegsrausch war,
da war das ja dann sofort, ah, jetzt haben wir den Ayatollah umgebracht,
jetzt machen wir hier irgendwie Regime-Change.
Und dann hat er, das wird nicht einfach so albert.
Ich mag eigentlich gar nicht über Trump reden, aber man muss es einfach bringen. ja, dann,
war er sofort in diesem Maduro-Modus und kam dann doch wirklich dann irgendwie
damit an mit ja, der Iran könnte ja jetzt keinen Führer bestimmen,
dem er nicht zustimmen würde.
Ja, wobei,
der beste Witz war, ja, also wir haben jetzt den Toller umgebracht und ja,
und haben sie denn jetzt jemanden im Auge, der dann vielleicht übernehmen könnt.
Ja, wir hatten da welche im Auge, aber die sind auch jetzt tot.
Und deren Stellvertreter sind jetzt auch tot.
Das heißt, wissen jetzt eigentlich gar nicht, wer jetzt übernehmen,
weil wir haben alle umgebracht, die wir kennen.
Wir kennen da jetzt gar niemanden mehr, weil alle tot sind.
Und so ungefähr kam Trump dann an.
Das ist natürlich auch Total albern.
Ja.
Also dieser Enthauptungsschlag, der mag zwar beeindruckend gewesen sein und
die Entführung von Maduro hat
auch wirklich da zu einer Änderung der Außenpolitik Kolumbiens geführt,
aber, Entschuldigung, nicht Kolumbiens, Venezuela geführt.
Aber das funktioniert hier im Iran einfach mal null.
Dementsprechend ist das ganze Gelaber über Regime-Change jetzt auch schon nicht
mehr in den Talking-Points.
Dann kommen sie jetzt wieder mit diesem, ja, wir müssen ja das Nuklearprogramm der Iraner zerstören.
Ja, aber das haben sie ja schon im Dezember behauptet, dass jetzt alles zerstört
wäre und damit wäre es ja jetzt vorbei.
Jetzt waren sie sich da wohl offenbar nicht mehr ganz so sicher.
Also gehen sie auf die low hanging fruits in der Außenkommunikation und sagen
so ja, wir müssen ja hier irgendwie die ganzen Raketen und Starteinrichtungen
und die Schiffe zerstören und die Navy und das ist wahrscheinlich auch das einzige,
was sie wirklich komplett,
entfernt bekommen die Navy, also sie haben ja sogar vor Sri Lanka mitten auf dem Ozean.
Ein großes Kriegsschiff der Iraner versenkt mit dem U-Boot Also mit Ihrem Robot.
Haben sie sich natürlich nicht um die Rettung der Besatzung gekümmert,
das hat dann irgendwie Sri Lanka übernommen, also nicht auf Anfrage der USA,
sondern hat die USA einfach mittlerweile jegliche Regeln der internationalen
Schifffahrt und des Kriegsrechts in irgendeiner Form missachten?
Ich meine, die Nummer war sowieso irgendwie merkwürdig.
Also sie haben wohl vorher sie auch gewarnt, sondern gesagt,
verlasst das Schiff so oder so, also wir werden euch gleich versenken.
Und die haben sich aber dann quasi geweigert, die Iraner das Schiff zu verlassen.
Dann gab es noch Meldungen, dass das iranische Schiff gar nicht bewaffnet war,
weil Indien und Sri Lanka in deren Hoheitsgewässern dort die Militärübung stattfand.
Auf der anderen Seite waren Teil der Militärübung auch Live-Fire-Exercises.
Das heißt, man weiß jetzt nicht, aber so, ja, also wirklich komische Nummer.
Und ja, wobei angeblich sollen diese sogar vorher gewarnt haben,
bleibt in den Hoheitsgewässern da.
Wenn ihr rauskommt, dann versenken wir euch.
So soll das irgendwie angeblich abgelaufen sein. Und die Iran haben gesagt,
fuck you, wir kommen jetzt hier raus.
So und haben sich dann mehr oder weniger versenken lassen. Ich meine, das Ding ist,
dass die Iraner immer wussten, dass wenn sie gezwungen sind,
in den Krieg zu kämpfen, dass ihre Flotte von größeren Kampfschiffen nicht lange überleben wird.
Und deswegen haben sie, glaube ich, auch gar nicht versucht,
da großartig Schiffe in Sicherheit zu bringen.
Und viele davon waren sowieso wahrscheinlich nicht in allerbestem Zustand,
sondern wo sie halt hauptsächlich eben reininvestiert haben,
sind so Tunnelanlagen mit Tausenden von kleinen Angriffsschiffen und Drohnen.
Und das ist im Prinzip wie Ukraine, also das wussten sie halt schon, ja.
Aber zurück nochmal jetzt zu den Kriegszielen.
Wie gesagt, Regime-Change wurde genannt, Nuklearprogramm stoppen,
dann möglichst irgendwie Militäreinrichtungen und dann Revolutionsgarden,
Polizei und Militärschwächen und das Problem ist,
Wenn du kein klares Ziel hast, ist, dass du dann unter Umständen Dinge tust,
oder das Militär Dinge tut, die dem einen oder anderen Kriegsziel einfach abträglich ist.
Also wenn du Regime-Change möchtest und bombardierst dann aber Zivilisten en
masse oder bombardierst dann irgendwie eine Mädchenschule oder so,
dann ist das natürlich Regime-Change eher abträglich.
Und so führt das eben dazu,
dass wenn du unklare Prioritäten hast, dass dann jeder irgendwie seins macht
und dass das aber auch politisch und strategisch einfach,
du magst dann zwar taktisch alle möglichen Erfolge erzielen,
aber torpedierst dann teilweise deine eigene Strategie mit diesen Schritten.
Und ja, das ist in dem Problem und in der Situation ist die USA.
Und ein Ding ist eben auch,
dass die USA zwar Flugzeugträger und Schiffe und Flugzeuge vor Ort haben und
U-Boote zwar in größerer Zahl,
aber doch wiederum nicht so
viele, um gleichzeitig offensiv und defensiv Operationen führen zu können.
Das ist auch dann von der Planung her viel komplizierter.
Und mit anderen Worten, sie können entweder jetzt Iran bombardieren oder sie
können versuchen, die Straße von Hormuz aufzubauen.
Offen zu machen und offen zu halten, aber eben nicht beides zugleich.
Da müssten sie halt dann komplett umschwenken oder doppelt so viel Militär ranbringen.
Und auch viele vergessen, zur Zeit des letzten Golfkriegs da unten,
also jetzt der große letzte Golfkrieg mit dem Einmarsch in Iran und dem Sturz von Saddam Hussein,
da hatte auch die USA noch eine Flotte, die wesentlich größer war.
Ronald Reagan hatte damals ein Gesetz durchgebracht, dass die amerikanische
Flotte mindestens aus 600 Schiffen bestehen muss. aktuell ist es ungefähr die Hälfte.
Glaube ich.
Und das heißt, ja, es ist einfach auch nicht genug Militär und,
Dieses Land, der Iran, ist eben auch groß, über 100 Millionen Einwohner.
Das ist flächenmäßig viermal so groß wie Deutschland ungefähr.
Aber ja, und hat aber nur ungefähr...
Also offiziell 87,8 Millionen Einwohner.
Okay, das klingt mir aber nach älteren Zahlen. Ich habe irgendwie schon über
100 Millionen irgendwo gehört, aber gut.
Das sei die offizielle UN-Schätzung von 2024, sagt Wikipedia.
Okay, also ein bisschen mehr als Deutschland. Hat aber nur ungefähr ein Viertel
oder Fünftel der Gebäude.
Also da wohnen mehr Leute in einem Gebäude zusammen. also fünfmal so in Deutschland.
Eine Person pro Gebäude oder in einem Gebäude lebt, leben dort fünf.
Aber es sind trotzdem fünf Millionen Gebäude. Und die USA hat bisher angeblich
5000 Ziele bombardiert.
So in zehn Tagen.
Und ja, also...
Mit anderen Worten, die USA hat auch einfach zu wenig Militär dort im Einsatz.
Und es klingt so ein bisschen wie auch der Anfang vom Ukraine-Krieg,
wo Russland 200.000 Mann versammelt hatte dort und es auch mathematisch einfach
relativ klar war, dass es nicht ausreicht.
Und hier haben wir jetzt zwar eine andere Lage, aber auch einfach nur die Dimensionen vergleicht.
Ja, sind die USA dann nicht in der Lage sein,
aus der Luft das Land zum Zusammenbruch zu bringen oder zu schwächen,
weil aus verschiedensten Gründen noch...
Danach sieht es aus, dass das sehr schwierig ist.
Ja, letzte Meldung war jetzt bei der US-Regierung, dass frühestens Ende März
jetzt Tanker von der Navy eskortiert werden.
Also sollen in drei Wochen so.
Aber wie das gehen soll und ob das passieren wird, wird stark bezweifelt.
Also die Iraner sagen, super, kommt, wir hätten nichts lieber gerne,
als dass hier mit unseren Schiffen in Sichtweite kommt.
Und wenn das passiert, ich bin mir relativ sicher, falls die USA Kriegsschiffe
in den Golf schickt werden, welche versendet werden.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Und das andere Problem ist, selbst wenn das jetzt funktionieren würde mit den
Eskorten, so Schützungen, also Selmas, Kleino meinte, die können vielleicht
10% des normalen Verkehrs durchbringen.
Also da können dann eher so 10 Schiffe am Tag können sie wahrscheinlich dadurch eskortieren.
Aber nicht die 100, die da eigentlich gerne durchfahren würden.
Ja, das wird nicht reichen, um die Versorgung, wie sie derzeit läuft, aufrechtzuerhalten.
Und die Preise werden natürlich dann auch nach wie vor hoch sein,
solange dieser Krieg läuft, sodass viele sicherlich diesen Aufwand auch scheuen werden.
Genau, ja, und stattdessen haben wir jetzt einfach einen Berg von Problemen.
Vor allem für die Region natürlich unten, aber auch für die ganze Welt.
Was wir jetzt in den Golfstaaten schon gesehen haben,
ja, Tourismus zusammengebrochen, Luftfahrt gestört, Öleinnahmen bleiben aus und ja.
Es ist halt vor allem ein Zusammenbruch ihres Modells.
Also es gilt jetzt mit Einschränkung für so Länder wie Kuwait,
die ja eigentlich im Tourismus jetzt keine große Rolle spielen.
Über Kuwait redet eigentlich keiner.
Irgendjemand wird da sicherlich auch hinfahren. Die haben bestimmt auch ein
paar ganz tolle Hotels, aber das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so der Ort.
Aber Dubai und Abu Dhabi, das ist ja allen voran das Land, was sich in den letzten
Jahrzehnten enorm als eine Wirtschaftskraft dort etabliert hat.
Die haben zwei riesen Drehkreuze für die internationale Luftfahrt mit dem Dubai
Airport und dem Abu Dhabi Airport mit zwei großen Airlines, die das alles dominieren.
Es ist ein super internationaler Ort geworden, weil sie halt einfach die ganze
Welt eingeladen haben, wenn du irgendwie eine halbwegs.
Gut ausgebildete Fachkraft bist und du arbeitest in irgendeinem Job,
mit dem die dort was anfangen können und das ist eigentlich nahezu alles ja, dann kannst du da,
einreiten, kannst du beantragen dort zu leben, verdienst das Doppelte zahlst
keine Steuern und so weiter und das,
Ganze geht natürlich einher mit so einem Sicherheitsversprechen.
Das ist sozusagen das Kernfeature ist.
Hier geht es dir gut, du hast irgendwie dein Shopping Mall, du hast irgendwie
dein Auto, du hast irgendwie den ganzen Konsum.
Wenn man so leben möchte, dann,
Das muss man dann auch wollen, ich würde das so nicht wollen,
aber es gibt halt Leute, die sehen das anders.
Aber hier kann dir keiner was, hier gibt es keine Kriminalität,
hier ist irgendwie alles safe.
Und dieses Versprechen, das bricht natürlich komplett auseinander,
wenn du dann in den Himmel guckst und es werden die ganze Zeit irgendwelche
anfliegenden Raketen abgeschossen oder noch schlimmer, nicht abgeschossen.
Also hier so auf der sagenumwobenen Palmen, Palm Jumeirah, das ist so ein ganz furchtbarer,
in das Meer reingebaute,
palmenartiger Villenstandort.
Da ist irgendwie eine Rakete in ein Hotel reingeflogen, das große Jumeirah Burj
Al Arab, das ist so, dass dieses ikonische Hotel,
was da so ein bisschen im Wasser steht, so aussieht wie so ein Segel, das hat was abbekommen.
Es sind auch schon Schahets auf den Flughäfen runtergekommen.
Es sind in der Nähe von dem größten Gebäude der Welt, dem Burj Khalifa,
ist was runtergekommen.
Also den Burj selber haben sie jetzt nicht getroffen, aber da haben wir zumindest
was in diese Richtung geschickt.
Ja und der Burj wurde dann aber evakuiert.
So trotzdem. Wegen Gefahr, habe ich gehört, wurde der gesamte Burj evakuiert.
Genau und das zerbricht das Geflecht, auf dem dieses Staatsversprechen basiert.
Das wird sehr, sehr, sehr lange nachwirken und diesen schier unaufhaltsamen
Aufstieg dieser Region erstmal ausbremsen.
Also mit jedem Tag, wo dieser Krieg weitergeht, sind natürlich die unmittelbaren Auswirkungen stark,
aber so die mittelbaren Auswirkungen, die werden noch über Jahre,
wenn nicht sogar über Jahrzehnte zu spüren sein.
Das gilt natürlich im eingeschränkten Maße auch für Katar, Bahrain,
die halt vor allem jetzt von den ganzen Öleinnahmen natürlich abhängig sind,
aber auch Dubai und Abu Dhabi sind halt wichtige Handelsnationen auch geworden
und vor allem läuft halt ein Großteil des internationalen Flugverkehrs über diese Flughäfen.
Das gilt nicht nur jetzt für Dubai und Abu Dhabi, sondern auch für Katar.
Auch Katar Airlines ist ja da groß im Spiel und da fliegt halt derzeit nichts
und sind irgendwie 500.000 Fluggäste da, die da pro Tag irgendwie nicht mehr
durchgeleitet werden durch diese Region.
Was die Ölversorgung betrifft, das haben wir ja schon besprochen,
aber da wollte ich nochmal so einen Aspekt aufbringen.
Saudi-Arabien ist nämlich damals schon im Iran-Irak-Krieg.
Wann war der nochmal ganz genau? War das 80er Jahre?
Ja, das war gleich in den 80ern.
80er, irgendwie so die Richtung. Sind die schon...
Also kurz nach der Revolution im Iran ging das ja los, hat der Irak angegriffen.
Erster Wolfkrieg 80 bis 88, genau, 80er Jahre.
Und da ist in Saudi-Arabien schon so, da haben sie es schon geahnt,
jetzt könnten wir unter Umständen mit unserem Golf ein Problem bekommen.
Und ja, tatsächlich existiert in Saudi-Arabien die sogenannte East-West-Pipeline,
auch Petrolein genannt,
die von den wichtigsten Ölproduktionsstandorten und Feldern in Osten Saudi-Arabiens,
das ist so auf der Höhe von Bahrain, quer durch die Saudi-Arabische Wüste und
durch das Gebirge im Westen durchgeht bis an den Hafen von Janbu.
Am Roten Meer.
Eine Strecke von wie lange ist das Ding ungefähr,
Ah, 1200 Kilometer, vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr.
Unglaublich. Ich habe mir das mal angeguckt, irgendwie auf Google Earth,
das Ding ist komplett unterirdisch verlegt worden.
Also so eingegraben, man sieht das von oben, dass es eingegraben ist.
Aber es ist jetzt keine Pipeline, die so oberhalb verläuft, sondern die ist
in den Boden gelegt und es sind irgendwie so 34 fette Rohre und sie können da
irgendwie sieben Millionen Barrel pro Tag irgendwie durchballern.
Zum Vergleich, 10 Millionen ist
glaube ich so in etwa der Output von Saudi-Arabien so in normalen Zeiten.
Mit anderen Worten, wenn die Pipeline jetzt funktioniert, was sie meines Wissens
tut, dann sind sie jetzt auch schon dabei, das in Betrieb zu nehmen.
Angeblich ziehen jetzt auch schon diverse Tanker vom Golf von Oman,
die also vor der Straße von Hormuz geparkt sind und fahren sozusagen ins Rote Meer rein.
Ich meine auch da ist ja nicht alles supi, da sind ja noch die Houthis,
das ist ja nochmal ein anderes Problem,
aber mit Tankern, die halt dann auch durch den Suezkanal durchkommen können,
könnte man halt an der Stelle auch die Versorgung Europas und theoretisch auch
Chinas wieder mit aufnehmen.
Und was das Öl vielleicht noch angeht,
so ab zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent der weltweiten Ölförderung kommt aus der Gegend, aus der Golfregion.
Es ist nicht alles komplett gesperrt.
Also die Iraner liefern noch Öl
an China und die Saudis an verschiedenen Stellen eben sagt es auch noch.
Aber es ist halt nicht nur das Öl,
wobei vielleicht ein wichtiger, wichtiger Ding ist, dass Europa relativ wenig
Öl aus der Region bezieht, 10 oder 20 Prozent nur.
So, während Asien ungefähr 80% seines Öls aus der Golfregion erhält.
Das heißt, das ist sagen wir noch mal.
Bisschen problematischer für Asien.
Aber neben eben Öl und Gas ist eben auch Dünger betroffen.
Spefelsäure als die meistverwendete Chemikalie,
die im Grunde genommen fast allen chemischen Prozessen und Metallverarbeitung
und Halbleiterproduktion und Medikamente und der Großteil geht in Düngerproduktion,
ungefähr die Hälfte der Schwefelsäure, glaube ich.
Aber die andere Hälfte steckt praktisch in fast jedem Produkt der chemischen Wertschöpfungskette.
Also ohne Schwefelsäure oder wenn Schwefelsäure knapp wird, wird,
dann brechen einfach komplett alle möglichen Lieferketten zusammen.
Und dann auch noch Helium wohl eine ganze Menge, was bestimmten technischen
Anwendungen auch recht wichtig ist. Und.
Ja, es gibt jetzt so Simulationsszenarien,
was jetzt angeht, wie weit der Ölpreis steigen wird und wann er sich wieder normalisieren wird,
abhängig davon, wie lange jetzt die Straße geschlossen bleibt.
Und was diese Simulation jetzt sagt,
so eine Monatsschließung gibt dann der Ölpreis bis 120,
130 hoch und braucht dann ungefähr ein halbes Jahr, bis er sich wieder normalisiert hat.
Ist aber jetzt die Straße drei Monate zu,
kann der Ölpreis bis irgendwie 250 Dollar pro Barrel hochgehen und die Normalisierung
wird dann ein Jahr dauern, so größenordnungsmäßig.
Ich meine, wie viel man auf die Simulation geben kann, weiß ich nicht.
Am Ende, was sich auch am Beispiel von Russland gezeigt hat, wenn denn dann Dinge...
Also es ist Probleme in der Weltschöpfungskette gibt, dass dann plötzlich die
Leute mehr Fantasie haben, was man denn sonst noch so machen kann.
Dass so oft die Auswirkungen nicht ganz so katastrophal sind,
wie man dann vorher geglaubt hat, weil man eben nicht damit gerechnet hat.
Aus wie vielen anderen Ecken jetzt meinetwegen plötzlich Öl kommen könnte.
Und ja, USA hat jetzt auch die Hälfte ihrer strategischen Reserve freigegeben und nicht nur die USA,
sondern die gesamte internationale Energieagentur, das heißt alle möglichen
Länder, geben jetzt auch noch zusätzlich Öl raus.
So bei den USA, nur noch weniger als halb gefüllt ist,
weil Biden hat dann irgendwann als Reaktion auf den Ukraine-Krieg und den Wegfall
Russlands als Lieferant,
hat er so ungefähr die Hälfte damals freigegeben.
Und die wurde dann nicht wieder aufgefüllt.
Und Trump wurde noch Anfang des Jahres gefragt, ob er denn gedenkt,
jetzt bei dem niedrigen Ölpreis die strategische Ölreserve wieder aufzufüllen und sagte dann nur dazu.
Na ja, warten noch ein bisschen, bis die Preise noch weiter unten sind.
So, das war Trumps öffentliches Statement dazu.
Und jetzt hat er eben auch noch mal wieder die Hälfte von der Hälfte freigegeben
und damit wird dann die amerikanische strategische Ölreserve auf einem Viertel
ungefähr dessen reduziert sein,
was sie in Spitzenzeiten mal war.
Ja, Reagan hatte das halt eingeführt nach dem Öl-Schock damals der 70er Jahre,
diese strategische Öl-Reserve.
Und auch Deutschland hat eine, und auch davon wird wahrscheinlich jetzt einiges
auf den Markt gehen, aber das ist im Moment fast ein Tropfen auf dem heißen
Stein, aber alles hilft halt.
Ja, aber Fakt ist, je länger die Straße zubleibt,
umso höher steigt der Preis und umso länger wird es dauern, bis sich das alles
wieder eingerüttelt hat.
Und es besteht zusätzlich dann die Gefahr, oder es wird nicht wieder so sein
wie vorher. Das ist das andere Ding.
Also es wird sicherlich permanente Veränderungen geben, die bleiben.
Also es wird keine Rückkehr zu Business as usual geben, denke ich.
Und vor allem besteht dann auch die Gefahr, man kann es mal so vergleichen,
wie ich diese Weltwirtschaft und gerade Öl ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Kreislauf,
das sind halt so Arterien und im Moment ist es so, als wenn jemand,
was weiß ich, die rechte Beinarterie gerade dir abgeklemmt hat und da kein Blut durchfließt.
Das kannst du, das geht eine Weile, aber irgendwann fängt halt das Bein an,
auch abzufallen, so je länger das, oder Schaden zuzunehmen.
Du kannst es halt nicht ewig geschlossen lassen, ohne dass bestimmte Dinge dann
komplett zusammenbrechen.
Also irgendwann fangen dann einfach an, Firmenpleite zu gehen.
Weil sie es nicht durchhalten und die kommen dann auch nicht mehr wieder.
So, dass dann Produkte oder Produktionskapazitäten oder so fallen einfach komplett
weg und sind nicht wieder da und kommen auch nicht mehr wieder.
Und das andere Ding, das hatten wir schon angesprochen, für die Golfstaaten,
da wird jetzt erwartet, dass die möglicherweise langfristig auf Distanz zu den
USA gehen könnten und lieber mit dem Iran sich direkt dann um eine Sicherheitsarchitektur dort bemühen.
Aber also die, was man von denen hört,
die sind da auch alle nur so minder begeistert von dem und sind natürlich auch
ein bisschen fest, weil sie vorher nicht gefragt oder einbezogen wurden oder so,
sondern die wurden davon genauso überrascht wie alle anderen.
Und sind natürlich deswegen auch zu Recht ein bisschen konsterniert.
Also die USA kann auf jeden Fall hier nur verlieren, in meinen Augen.
Also ich sehe ehrlich gesagt überhaupt kein Szenario, wo die USA profitiert.
Also der ganze Krieg kostet Sie Unmengen an Geld.
Also es gibt verschiedenste Schätzungen, ist schwierig zu beantworten,
aber ein bis zwei Milliarden pro Tag müssen Sie schon investieren in diesen riesigen Aufwand.
Man muss sich vorstellen, wie viele Leute und wie viel Kriegsgerät da ist,
wie viel Ordnance, also wie viel Raketenwaffenmaterial hier zum Einsatz kommt.
Das kostet einfach unglaublich viel. Gut, USA-Geld ist immer so ein bisschen
ihr geringstes Problem, zumindest noch.
Aber was sie halt hier an Vertrauen und an Allianzbereitschaft einbüßen werden,
das lässt sich glaube ich mit Geld überhaupt nicht mehr aufwiegen.
Ja, und es ist halt auch ein komplett illegaler Krieg.
Also kommt noch dazu, es ist halt eigentlich ein illegaler Angriffskrieg,
der völkerrechtlich verboten ist, weswegen sie das dann auch nicht Krieg nennen.
Also die USA haben damit einfach so viel Kapital auch weltweit verspielt und
auch im Land und außerhalb des Landes.
Also zu den Kosten, ich habe es auch mal überschlagen, also Militär gab jetzt
die erste Rechnung, das irgendwie zwölf Milliarden irgendwie die erste Woche
gekostet hat wohl an militärischen Kosten.
Und dann, wenn du einfach nur rechnest, wie viel mehr für Öl bezahlt werden muss,
ist es für die USA auch ungefähr fast eine Milliarde am Tag,
was der amerikanische Verbraucher mehr zahlen muss für die Ölimporte.
Und weltweit ungefähr 10 Milliarden.
Also die Welt kostet das halt richtig viel und.
Ja, wenn wir jetzt mal in die Richtung gehen,
was sind denn so Worst-Case-Szenarien oder Best-Case-Szenarien,
wie das jetzt weitergehen kann,
dann, ja, ich weiß nicht, wollen wir mit Best oder mit Worst Cases anfangen?
Mit den Worst Case Szenarien, damit wir uns danach wieder ein bisschen einfangen können.
Ja, also um dort meine Fantasie so ein bisschen anzuregen, habe ich mir dann auch mal angeschaut,
was sind so die üblichen oder was sind so gewisse Fringe Analysten,
die auch beim Ukraine-Krieg so immer nur Doom gesehen haben oder das halt für
eine NATO-Erweiterung für einen großen Fehler gehalten haben.
Was die denn jetzt so zum Krieg sagen.
Und war einmal interessant irgendwie Ted Postol,
ehemaliger UN-Waffeninspektor und ist Professor und ist halt groß geworden damit
oder bekannt geworden, dass er vor Jahrzehnten,
nachdem der Irak mit Skat-Raketen Israel angegriffen hat,
analysiert hat die tatsächlichen Abfangs.
Und festgestellt hat, dass die total falsch waren, sodass die ganzen Meldungen,
was denn abgefangen wurde.
Dass das ja komplett daneben lag.
Und der hat daneben Foto- und Filmanalysen und wurde dann auch vom Senat dann
auch ein Buch geschrieben.
Und ja, also er hackt natürlich immer noch in diese Kerbe und hat da sicherlich
auch ein Stück weit recht.
Also er ist dabei extremer und sagt, dass das alles Quatsch ist,
dass es immer noch im einstelligen Prozentbereich liegt,
wo er vielleicht bei modernen ballistischen Raketen, wie er schon erklärt,
durchaus Recht haben kann, weil die alle möglichen Dinge machen,
die es wirklich schwer machen, die abzufangen.
Und er ist der Meinung,
dass Netanyahu ein selbstmörderischer Narzisst ist und dass Israel den Iran
atomar angreifen könnte,
wenn die Amerikaner jetzt einfach sagen,
jetzt ist Schluss und wir gehen da jetzt raus.
Und Israel meint, seine Ziele noch nicht erreicht zu haben.
Ich halte das für eher unwahrscheinlich.
Aber Israel hat halt Atomwaffen und man würde jetzt nicht auf absolut Null setzen können, das Risiko.
Also was aber, worauf er auch aufmerksam gemacht hat und das ist wahr,
das ist auch noch wichtig,
Iran könnte in Wochen 10 bis 20 Uranbomben bauen. Und,
Der Witz ist, was ich halt jetzt das erste Mal verstanden habe,
ist, dass Netanyahu Recht damit hatte, als er seit Jahrzehnten behauptet hat,
der Iran steht nur eine Woche vor dem Bau einer Bombe.
Wurde er dann so verspottet, weil er immer...
Du hast schon seit 30 Jahren erzählt.
Seit 30 Jahren erzählt er, Der Iran ist kurz davor, eine Atombombe bauen zu können.
Und er hat recht, der Iran ist tatsächlich seit Jahrzehnten wirklich nur eine
Woche oder zwei vom Bau einer Atombombe entfernt.
Also seit sie jetzt genügend hoch angereichertes Uran haben.
Der einzige Grund, warum sie das nicht gebaut haben, ist, dass der Ayatollah gesagt hat,
Atombomben sind böse, sind irgendwie nicht haram und kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
So Atombomben kommen ja nicht ins Haus.
Das war seine ganz klare Anweisung.
Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn wir dann fragen, okay, wieso hat denn der Iran nach Schätzungen
2000 Milliarden ausgegeben oder an Schaden in Kauf genommen,
um jetzt sein Atomprogramm,
Und das war dann, also man wollte sich dann einfach irgendein Druckmittel einfach
aufbauen oder erhalten.
Es geht also in den internationalen Beziehungen dann immer, wer hat wie viel
Leverage? Und das Atomprogramm war dann für Iran quasi in erster Linie Leverage.
Wir wollten jetzt nicht die Bombe bauen, aber wie Abschreckung eben auch funktioniert,
sondern nur glaubhaft den Eindruck erwecken, sie könnten eine Bombe bauen, wenn immer sie wollten.
Und das ist ihnen auch gelungen. So.
Und ja, also wie gesagt, Postol fürchtet, dass das eben nuklear eskalieren könnte,
dass Israel eventuell Atomwaffen ins Spiel bringt und wenn das dann passiert,
dass dann der Iran tatsächlich sich entscheidet, die Bomben zu bauen,
wobei es vielleicht sich auch so entscheidet.
Und die Technik, also wenn du eine Artillerie-Kanone bauen kannst und das Material hast,
dann ist das eine Woche oder zwei, also du kannst wahrscheinlich dann irgendwelche
existierenden Panzerkanonen oder so,
oder Hobbitzen einfach umbauen, indem du da einen Urankern verschießt in einen
Uran-Target und dann hast du so eine Hiroshima-Bombe.
Und wie gesagt, wenn Iran wollte, weil er 10 bis 20 Stück davon und hat auch
Trägersysteme so also, sofern, aber wie gesagt, im Moment, es gibt keine Anhaltspunkte dafür,
dass sich da an der Ablehnung von Atomwaffen irgendwas geändert hat,
weil so nützlich sind die dann am Ende auch nicht.
Ja, zumindest die Ablehnung von Ayatollah Khamini, der ja jetzt von Ayatollah
Khamini ersetzt wird und für den gilt ja diese Aussage zunächst einmal nicht.
Ich meine gut, das wurde religiös begründet und die müssten sich dann eine neue
religiöse Begründung ausdenken,
warum die jetzt dann plötzlich doch haram sind und warum man jetzt nicht mehr in die Hölle kommt.
Wenn man eine Atomwaffe anfasst oder baut oder so.
Aber ich denke mal, das stellt kein unüberwindliches Hindernis dar.
Insofern ist da jetzt die Gefahr eher gestiegen.
Also es gibt, das ist jedenfalls, Ted Postol so malt da dieses Bild von einem
Atomkrieg, von einem Potenziellen an die Wand.
Und so, ja, Scott Ritter wiederum,
so ein ehemaliger amerikanischer Militär, der da auch eher so zu einem nützlichen
Idioten für Russland geworden ist und da ziemlich viele Sprüche loslässt.
Hier hat er dann die Kerbe geschlagen, ja, dass der Krieg jetzt die Rettung
für Russland ist, weil jetzt die Ölpreise in die Höhe gehen und kümmern.
Dass die Sanktionen jetzt von Russland teilweise weggenommen werden und dass
Putin jetzt auch Trump beeinflussen kann, indem er Trump verspricht.
Dass er hilft bei der Friedensstiftung.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Russland allzu viel Leverage hat gegenüber Iran, aber China.
Also wenn es darum ginge, für Szenarien, die jetzt nicht ganz so sind.
Was könnte Iran dazu bringen, selber aufzuhören, dann ist es in erster Linie
China, die dann sagen, Schluss mit lustig und eventuell auch Russland.
Aber dass Russland nicht so viel hat, um den Iran zu beeinflussen,
das weiß halt Trump nicht.
Und ja, deswegen können Putin Trump versprechen, ja, die machen schon, was wir ihnen sagen.
Und wenn du jetzt nur die Sanktionen aufhebst und so weiter.
Also ja, also Scott Ritter, ja, ist dann auch so angeblich, ja,
Russland könnte jetzt legal England angreifen, was irgendwie Storm Shadow und Flamingo liefert.
Aber Putin möchte halt jetzt Stama nicht fördern, wenn jetzt England angreifen
und Stama sei sowieso erledigt.
Das ist mit Gewirr, Pavel.
Ja, das ist jetzt auf der rechten Seite.
Ich finde, es ist immer ganz interessant, da mal hinzugucken.
Und dann vielleicht als letztes aber noch John Mersheimer, der der seriöseste,
würde ich sagen, von diesen Analysten ist, aber der sich vor allem damit hervorgetan hat,
die NATO-Erweiterung zu kritisieren und sagen, ja, und man hätte Russland irgendwie
die Ukraine überlassen sollen und so weiter.
Und ja, Mörschheimer sagt so, die USA haben den Konflikt.
Und er ist der Meinung, dass der Iran am Ende sogar die Aufhebung aller Sanktionen
und Reparationen rausschlagen könnte,
um die Straße von Hormuz wieder frei zu geben.
Bin mir da nicht ganz so sicher, aber es ist auf jeden Fall,
sieht es im Moment so aus, als wenn Iran tatsächlich die besseren Karten hat.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich der Konflikt sich da hinziehen wird, die Straße erstmal
zu bleibt, ist auf jeden Fall die Weltwirtschaft in einer massive Krise,
Rezession, Depression, weiß ich nicht.
Unruhen, Hunger und Konflikte in vielen Teilen der Welt und Massenflucht.
Also wenn wir Deutschland oder so, oder die entwickelten reichen Länder,
wir können uns das erlauben, mal für ein Jahr ein bisschen höhere Energiekosten,
zu haben, aber es gibt eben weltweit viele Länder, die leben jetzt schon am
Rande des Existenzminimums.
Und Und für die kann das einfach der komplette Zusammenbruch des Staates bedeuten,
so wie Nigeria oder andere Länder, die jetzt sowieso schon sich kaum ernähren können.
Und wenn jetzt sich der Preis für Dünger verdoppelt und so, also können auf
jeden Fall davon ausgehen, dass es zu mehr Konflikten kommen wird,
teilweise in Teilen der Welt, wo wir gar nicht vermuten,
dass die betroffen sind.
Aber eben arme Länder werden halt einfach mal potenziell massiv betroffen sein.
Wir könnten neue Flüchtlingsbewegungen sehen, wir können neue Bürgerkriege sehen
oder überhaupt mehr Krieg.
Also das sehe ich irgendwie als das Wahrscheinlichste an.
Und mit jedem Tag, wo die Straße weiter zu ist,
also jetzt kein Schwarz oder Weiß, aber mit jedem Tag wird es teurer und dauert länger.
Und die Planung der USA, meiner Meinung nach, haben die so eine Kampagne auch
wie gegen die Hutus von vier Wochen ungefähr geplant.
Ja, das ist das, glaube ich, wovon sie irgendwie ausgegangen sind.
Wir bomben da vier Wochen lang rein, so ungefähr, und gucken dann, was passiert.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob es so lange überhaupt durchgehen wird.
Das hängt jetzt ganz stark vom Ölpreis ab.
Also je mehr der Ölpreis steigt, umso schneller werden wir ein Ende sehen.
Aber der Iran hat eben eine Menge mitzureden und auf eine Art und Weise befindet
sich die USA noch in einer schlimmeren Position als Russland mit der Ukraine.
Putin könnte sich jederzeit aus der Ukraine zurückziehen oder den Krieg für
beendet erklären, wenn er wollte und irgendwie Sieg reklamieren und ja.
Aber Trump kann halt einen Sieg nur für sich reklamieren, wie gesagt,
wenn die Straße wieder offen ist.
Solange kein Öl fließt, ist der Krieg nicht zu Ende.
Und da kann er machen, was er will.
Und wie gesagt, der Iran hat da eine ganze Menge mitzureden.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal gucken, okay, was wären denn jetzt positivere Szenarien noch?
Ich meine, bis vor kurzem, und das ist jetzt auch noch nicht auf Null runter,
dass es eine Revolution im Iran gibt und mit einer Annäherung an den Westen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit davon ist jetzt nicht 0%, aber nachdem,
was jetzt wieder wie der Krieg gelaufen ist, ist es jetzt praktisch ausgeschlossen.
Dass es eine Evolution gibt.
Ja, also dass es jetzt irgendein Regime-Change in Richtung eines pro-westlichen
Regimes gibt oder so, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist extrem gering.
Und dass der Iran jetzt kapituliert und USA und Israel gewinnen und irgendwie
Iran unter Aufsicht stellen und dann ja,
das ist sich auch für extrem unwahrscheinlich oder auch praktisch ausgeschlossen hat.
Vielleicht noch eher dann noch die Revolution, als dass irgendwie eine Kapitulation erfolgen könnte.
Ein bisschen höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass der Iran dann in,
Wenn es dort Bürgerkrieg ausbricht und das Ganze in Chaos zerfällt und die Nachbarländer
und so teilweise einmarschieren und wir dann so eine Art Syrien-Szenario kriegen,
das sagt möglich, aber auch nicht sehr wahrscheinlich.
Trotzdem mal ganz interessant an der Stelle auch mal zu schauen.
Ich meine, Iran ist ja kein homogenes Land, sondern auch da ist es eigentlich ein Vielvölkerstaat.
Das wird jetzt normalerweise so nicht wahrgenommen. Man schaut halt immer so
auf die eigentlichen Perser, aber du hast halt im Norden, Nordwesten des Landes
eine relativ starke kurdische Minderheit, die ja auch kräftig zu leiden hat.
Da wurde ja schon viel darüber spekuliert, ob die eingreifen.
Das würde mich ehrlich gesagt derzeit ein bisschen überraschen,
aber muss man mal gucken.
Dann hast du im Norden auch eine aserbaidschanische Aserie.
Und mehr als in Aserbaidschan leben. Also mehr Aseris leben im Iran als in Aserbaidschan.
Genau, und da ist ja auch schon Raketen auf Aserbaidschan gehabt.
So ist das auf jeden Fall auch ein bisschen unruhig.
Und was man auch nicht außer Acht lassen darf, sind so die eher dem Pakistan
nahestehenden Völker so im Osten des Landes, die halt nicht schiitisch sind.
Also da ist schon...
Sprengkraft drin, aber man darf auch nicht vergessen, der Iran ist ja jetzt
nicht seit 20 Jahren in dieser Verfassung, sondern das geht halt jetzt seit den 70er Jahren,
das ist ein extrem eingefahrenes Regime und da muss schon sehr viel Gewalt aus
sehr vielen Richtungen kommen und damit meine ich halt jetzt nicht von außen von den Amerikanern,
sondern aus dem Volk selber heraus mit einer ordentlichen Strategie,
um dieses Land aus dem Lot zu bringen.
Auch ich würde sagen, nicht komplett ausgeschlossen, aber derzeit auch nicht
unbedingt besonders wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich meine, und dann vielleicht mal auch was ein möglicher Verlauf ist,
der so zu den nicht Worst Cases gehört ist,
dass ja die USA eben dann doch halt Mission Accomplished erklärt und Israel zurückpfeift.
Und dann aber vorher eben auch dann mit China und Russland irgendwo vereinbart
hat, dass die genug Druck auf den Iran machen,
um dann den Beschluss vorläufig einzustellen.
Zu stellen. Erinnert mich, wie man ein bisschen an das Prinzip,
wie in größeren Parteien die unterschiedlichen Fraktionen diszipliniert werden.
Und zwar.
In der Partei greifst du jetzt nicht jemanden vom anderen Flügel an,
der jetzt irgendwie aus der Reihe tanzt, sondern du gehst dann zu dem Chef von
dem anderen Flügel und sagst, du, der tanzt ja aus der Reihe.
Und dann wird der sozusagen von der eigenen Seite diszipliniert und ähnlich.
Könnte das eigentlich auch nur laufen dann mit Iran, also der USA kann da irgendwie
noch so auf den Tisch schauen, wahrscheinlich die einzigen,
die jetzt wirklich da den Iran wahrscheinlich bewegen können,
seit der Alliierten, also sprich Russland, aber Russland hat meiner Meinung
nach nicht so viel Leverage, nicht so viel Hebel.
Das würde ich auch sagen und vor allem hat Russland auch nicht so viel Interesse daran.
Sie profitieren ja von dem hohen Ölpreis derzeit, sie profitieren in gewisser
Hinsicht auch von der Ablenkung und von daher,
ja China sehe ich total, dass China einfach dahin geht und sagt,
so Leute ist jetzt der Kindergarten mal beendet, wir müssen jetzt hier mal wieder
normale Welt spielen, USA kriegen das eh nicht auf die Kette,
aber ihr haltet jetzt hier auch mal Füße still, dann helfen wir euch auch ein bisschen.
Ihr habt ja einen gewissen Wiederaufbaubedarf, da werden wir uns schon irgendwie einig.
Also das halte ich durchaus für wahrscheinlich, dass auch die USA diesen Weg gehen müssen.
Ja, und je höher denn der Ölpreis steigt, umso wahrscheinlicher wird der Weg.
Aber das führt dann natürlich dazu, dass der Iran dann wieder aufrüsten wird.
Und dann potenziell, dass Israel und USA dann wieder in ein, zwei,
drei Jahren oder so wieder hingehen und wegbomben oder dann vielleicht tatsächlich
dann irgendwann eine Bodeninitiative oder so zusammenkriegen,
was aber auch eher unwahrscheinlich ist.
Aber damit ist das Problem nicht auf Dauer gelöst.
Andere noch möglichen Weg, dass es nicht ganz so schlimm wird,
habe ich vorhin schon mal erwähnt,
aber dass die Welt halt einfach andere Mittel und Wege findet,
den Energie- und Rohstoffbedarf zu decken.
Und dadurch dann Iran sich wieder komplett unter Embargo wiederfindet und dann
eben kapitulieren muss.
Und das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt schwarz-weiß, aber wie gesagt,
vielleicht kommt es nicht ganz so schlimm, weil man eben andere Mittel und Wege findet.
Aber ja, wir werden sehen.
Das vielleicht als positiver Aspekt, ich meine, wenn der Ölpreis über 90 Dollar steigt.
Dann wird auch die Ölindustrie nervös, weil sie gar kein Interesse daran hat, dass Öl zu teuer ist.
Denn wenn Öl zu teuer ist, dann überlegen alle vielleicht was anderes zu nehmen als Öl.
Ich finde es immer wieder ein bisschen erschreckend, wenn man sich jetzt mal
die ökonomischen Produkte, die hier von diesen Golfstaaten geliefert werden, anschaut.
Was alles noch so an dieser fossilen Förderung hängt.
Weil man denkt dann immer so Öl, Benzin, Diesel, ja okay, jetzt fahren wir alle
Elektroautos, passt schon.
Dann haben wir natürlich die ganze Heizungssituation mit dem Erdgas,
was natürlich auch aus dieser Region kommt.
Aber in dieser Öl- und Gasproduktion hängt ja auch noch so viel Sekundäres dran.
Und wir haben es ja schon erwähnt, also auch diese Schwefelsäureproduktion,
diese Stickstoffdüngerproduktion ist einfach ein Abfallprodukt dieser ganzen
Öl- und Gasförderung und das lässt sich natürlich nicht von heute auf morgen ersetzen.
Und da gibt es auch noch gar keine klaren Strategien, wie das jetzt zum Beispiel
eben bei der Mobilität ist.
Also alles, was sich mit Strom umsetzen lässt, lässt sich theoretisch eben auch
mit Solar und Wind und anderen klugen Systemen und Batterien lösen.
Nur in diesen anderen Bereichen, insbesondere im Agrar- und Ernährungsbereich,
fehlt es glaube ich noch an solchen Alternativen oder zumindest an klaren Perspektiven dafür.
Alles, was Plastik ist, Plastik, Thea, Ölung.
Das kommt noch dazu. Oder diese klassischen Öl-basierten Sachen.
Aber ich denke, wenn du heute mal jemanden fragst, was hat der Dünger mit einer
Erdgasförderung zu tun, dann wissen die meisten Leute überhaupt nicht, wovon die Rede ist.
Ja, wenn man jetzt mal einfach nur ab von jeder Spekulation oder politischer
Färbung ein paar Fakten zusammenfasst, dann kann man erst mal sagen,
die Straße von Hormuz ist faktisch zu für westliche Schiffe.
Und die US-Navy traut sich auch nicht ein.
Das sehen wir, also das ist einfach mal Fakt.
Auf der anderen Seite, was wir eben sehen, ist auch, dass die USA täglich Hunderte bis.
An die tausend Ziele angreifen, also USA-Bomben nach wie vor im Iran Dinge weg,
aber wir wissen nicht, was der tatsächliche Schaden jetzt ist, aber man geht davon aus,
dass bisher so zwischen tausend und zweitausend Iraner getötet wurden in diesen Angriffen.
Was natürlich auf der einen Seite erschreckende Zahlen sind, aber wenn man dann sagt,
dass 10.000 bis 30.000 Iraner bei Aufständen vor ein paar Wochen getötet wurden
oder wenn man das jetzt generell mit Krieg vergleicht oder allein nur sagt,
dass diese 2.000 waren jetzt alles Militärangehörige oder vorwiegend Militärangehörige,
Dann kann man jetzt auch sehen,
dass die Armee jetzt zwar vielleicht weniger Zeugs hat,
aber nicht sichtbar ist, dass die jetzt irgendwie tatsächlich groß geschwächt
sind oder geschwächt sind zu einem Grad, hatte, dass sie nicht existent sind,
sehen wir halt nur im Moment nicht allzu viel der USA entgegen zu setzen,
aber sind auch nicht komplett wehr- und hilflos.
Also sie haben auch noch genug Zähne offenbar und genug Zähne,
um zu verhindern, dass amerikanische Schiffe in den Golf fahren, auf jeden Fall. So.
Und es ist halt massives Eskalationspotenzial noch da.
Mit anderen Worten, es gibt eine Menge, was noch nicht angegriffen wurde oder
noch nicht angegriffen wird oder nur in geringem Ausmaß angegriffen wurde.
Zum Beispiel die Angriffe jetzt auf die Ölanlagen, die der Iran durchgeführt
hat, waren mehr symbolischer Natur.
Also da wurden jetzt keine gewaltigen Zerstörungen gemacht.
Angeblich sind die Raffinerien, die getroffen wurden und so,
auch wieder repariert, schon in wenigen Tagen. Das war halt nur mehr vom Iran her.
Wir könnten, wenn wir wollten.
Und ich glaube, wenn der Iran wollte, wäre er schon in der Lage,
mit dem, was er noch hat, Nennenswertschäden anzurichten an den Ölanlagen.
Und umgekehrt aber auch, also die USA oder Israel,
die haben zwar jetzt diese eine Raffinerie bei Teheran angegriffen,
aber das war jetzt keine unbedingt zentrale Stelle oder nicht unbedingt wichtig für den Export oder so.
Und die ganzen Ölförder- und Exporteinrichtungen und so sind bisher von den
USA und Israel nicht wirklich in nennenswertem Maße angegriffen worden.
Und nachdem die Israelis das gemacht haben, wurden sie auch sofort zurückgepfiffen.
Weil das natürlich auch jeder sehen kann, wenn das so weit eskaliert,
dass auf beiden Seiten sämtliche Förderanlagen dort erstmal zerstört werden.
Und zwar dann die Straße von Hormuz dann frei ist,
aber die ganzen Ölterminals und Ölförderanlagen und Speicher und so erstmal
kaputt sind und erstmal monatelang repariert werden müssen,
dann ist das auch eine absolute Katastrophe.
Ja, also.
Eskalationspotenzial besteht, aber ja, ich rechne damit, dass es jetzt,
noch ein paar Wochen so weitergehen wird, wie das jetzt weitergeht, das tendenziell,
aber man kann schon sehen, dass tendenziell USA und Israel sich mit den Bomben
zurückhalten, praktisch, um eben nicht groß weiter zu eskalieren.
Und ja, der Iran bleibt auf absehbare Zeit weiter im Kampf.
Und.
Ja, also wenn der Ölpreis so um die 90 bleibt,
wie er jetzt aktuell ist und nicht schnell wesentlich höher geht,
dann wird es auch keine Änderungen geben auf beiden Seiten.
Aber Iran hätte den Ölpreis lieber bei 250, 300.
Das war deren Drohung, dass das ihr Ziel ist, das da hinzutreiben.
Aber das Einzige oder das Hauptsächliche, was der Iran im Moment tut,
ist genug Schaden anzurichten, dass die Schiffe nicht durchfahren durch die Straße.
Das ist das, was ich so sehen kann und ansonsten hier und da mal ein paar Raketen
auf amerikanische oder andere Militärbasen abzufeuern,
um auch mehr amerikanische Tote zu produzieren, um die politische Situation
in den USA zu beeinflussen.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall eine...
Ein Vorgang, der sehr viel Auswirkungen haben kann und wahrscheinlich auch wird,
denn es ist ja auch eine Schwächung der USA, also nicht nur so auf politischer
Ebene, sondern jetzt auch einfach mal auf militärischer Ebene.
Wenn die jetzt vier Wochen lang alles rausballern, was sie irgendwie haben,
dann haben die auch ein Versorgungsproblem.
Die Verluste sind dann sicherlich signifikant.
Das ist insofern natürlich auch für die Ukraine ein Problem,
wenn das an den Reserven geht,
aus denen unter Umständen dieses Aufkaufprojekt der Europäer rauszehrt.
Ja.
Wobei generell, ja, die Schätzungen, also von Perun zum Beispiel, sind auch von anderen.
Der USA werden jetzt nicht die Waffen ausgehen allgemein, vor allem nicht die Bomben und so.
Und dem Iran werden jetzt auch erstmal nicht die Raketen ausgehen oder Abschussbasen
oder sonst wie so, sondern...
Die Einschätzung ist, dass beide
Seiten noch genug haben, um das noch monatelang weiter durchzuziehen.
Aber es kostet die USA natürlich und die Welt immens viel Geld, gerade was da passiert.
Vernichtet wird. Und das ist dann so ein bisschen eher das Problem.
Und auch pro Tag sagen könnte, statt dort jetzt Krieg zu führen,
könnte die USA auch 3000 Wohnhäuser bauen jeden Tag so in den USA.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt den ökonomischen Schaden sieht, vergleichen wir mit,
dass jeden Tag, den dieser Krieg weitergeht,
der Iran in der Lage ist, 3000 Häuser in den USA in die Luft zu sprengen, ohne Tote jetzt,
und der amerikanische Steuerzahler diese 3000 Häuser wieder errichten muss.
Oder eben 3.000 Häuser nicht bauen kann.
Und wenn man die anderen ökonomischen Auswirkungen macht, dann sind es eher
3.000 bis 10.000 Häuser am Tag,
die nicht gebaut werden können, weil dieser Krieg gerade geführt wird.
Das sind sozusagen die Dimensionen. Deshalb eben der Iran vor allem im Spiel
bleiben muss und in der Lage sein muss,
die Straße weiter zuzuhalten, um am Ende siegreich daraus zu gehen.
Ja, okay. Wir müssen langsam mal zum Ende kommen.
Ich will nochmal sagen, wir haben jetzt hier mal wieder eine sehr technische,
technokratische Sicht auf diese ganze Situation geliefert.
Es ist vollkommen umstritten, dass es eine große Freude wäre,
wenn denn jetzt die USA mit einem ihrer erklärten Ziele à la Regime-Change tatsächlich
in irgendeiner Form etwas voranbringen würde.
Nur sieht es halt einfach mal nicht danach aus, dass das iranische Regime absolut
abgeschafft gehört und für die Welt jenseits der Straße von Hormuz ein Problem darstellt, ist klar.
Also dieses auf Hass aufgebaute System,
was sich halt immer wieder an Israel abarbeitet und damit den ganzen Nahen Osten
destabilisiert, auch mit ihren Unterstützungsmaßnahmen für die Kämpfer im Jemen.
Das ist ein großes Problem und es wäre ja ganz toll, wenn jetzt irgendwie so
ein Militäreinsatz, den muss man ja nicht gleich so illegal betreiben,
in irgendeiner Form dazu führen würde, dass dieses Regime ein Ende findet.
Nur das zeichnet sich offensichtlich hier nicht ab und am Ende,
wenn wir es auch weiterhin mit einem Iran zu tun haben, der jetzt unter Umständen
noch weiter radikalisiert ist und das irgendwie kann nicht gut sein.
Nicht nur das, sondern ich finde mich
halt auch in einem massiven
Gefühlskonflikt wieder so und kann mich weder jetzt mit den Amerikanern irgendwie
sympathisieren oder ihnen Erfolg wünschen bei dem, was sie tun,
noch kann ich irgendwie mit dem Iran sympathisieren.
Aber eigentlich fast eher in der momentanen Situation finde ich mich irgendwie zu meinem Erstaunen,
so mehr auf der Seite vom Iran wieder, obwohl es eigentlich ein Feind ist und
wie gesagt, dieses Regime,
all das, woran ich glaube an Werten und vielleicht nicht alles mit Füßen tritt,
Aber eben sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr vieles.
Und ja.
Die Amerikaner sind eigentlich die Baddies.
So in dem, oder es sind, ich meine, die Iraner sind auch die Baddies,
weil die haben den Russen, darf man auch nicht vergessen,
unter anderem die Schaheds geliefert und helfen halt, die Ukraine dort anzugreifen,
aber so auf der anderen Seite ist es klar ein illegaler Angriffskrieg und.
Einer, vor dem wahrscheinlich alle gewarnt haben und der aber jetzt massiv eben
in der Welt Sympathien für Iran erzeugt und Antipathien nicht nur leider gegen
die USA, sondern auch gegen den Westen.
Wir werden halt schon gesehen, auch als Teil, also jetzt Europa.
Als Teil natürlich der westlichen Allianz.
Das heißt, wir haben potenziell auch jetzt mit mehr Terroranschlägen,
können wir möglicherweise rechnen, als Folge dessen und vielleicht irgendwie
dann nochmal einen neuen Krieg gegen den Terror sehen werden,
Ausweitung von Überwachungsmethoden und, und, und.
Also alles sehr unappetitlich und Europa tatsächlich so ein bisschen,
ich würde mir wünschen, dass Europa da auch ein bisschen mehr sich ins Zeug
legen würde und auch einfach mal klarer der USA Ansagen machen würde, so nicht.
Und die Einzige war Spanien, die sich da geäußert hatten.
Da hat Merz leider enttäuscht. Der hat einfach nur die Klappe gehalten.
Gut, kann ich auch verstehen.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich an Merz' Stelle wäre und mit Trump zusammensitzen,
würde ich mir auch noch denken, lass den Alten mal, also bloß nicht provozieren
den Alten, weil der ist unberechenbar.
Das lassen wir mal. Aber trotzdem, weiß ich nicht,
ich würde mir eher wünschen, dass da einfach mal mehr klare Kante auch von Europa
gezeigt wird und dass man sich
mehr an Spanien orientiert und weniger an Deutschland oder gar Europa.
An anderen Ländern.
Ich denke, auf jeden Fall hat sich Trump keinen Gefallen getan mit dieser ganzen Aktion.
Und vor allem das Verhältnis zum Golf, was ja bisher immer sehr proamerikanisch
war. Das wird sich, glaube ich, durch diese Nummer auch erheblich ändern.
Und ja, ich bin mal gespannt, wie es hier mit den Glitzerwelten von Dubai und Abu Dhabi weitergeht.
Weil von dem Schock werden die sich so schnell nicht erholen.
Genau, und wenn es so richtig in die Hose geht, dann können wir uns warm anziehen.
Ich hätte schon wieder überlegt, ob ich Vorräte, Lebensmittelvorräte anlegen.
Kauft Gold.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, gucke ich, ob irgendwelche Produkte
schon ausbleiben oder so.
Also ich fand das gerade in den ersten Tagen wieder sehr bedrohlich, was da passiert.
Und das Eskalationspotenzial ist größer als das bei der Ukraine oder vergleichbar.
Leider.
Jetzt auch ein Herd. Aber vielleicht führt es ja dazu,
dass das nicht so weitergeht, weil wenn man sich jetzt überlegt,
wenn die USA jetzt auch wieder so à la Venezuela super Erfolg gehabt hätten,
welche Länder dann als nächstes dran sind.
Wahrscheinlich Kuba wäre als nächstes dran, aber dann könnte sich Trump wieder
Kanada oder Grönland zuwenden oder Mexiko so mit seinem Großamerika.
Und insofern, ja, hat man jetzt fast das Gefühl,
so wie die Ukrainer jetzt Europa verteidigen gegen die Russen,
verteidigt jetzt der Iran die Welt gegen die Amerikaner, wenn man das so weiter
spinnen möchte. Und ausgerechnet Iran.
Na gut, lass uns zum Ende kommen, Pabbel.
Das sollte erstmal reichen. Das sind so unsere Gedanken.
Wir werden das weiter beobachten, aber uns trotzdem auch erstmal wieder ein
bisschen auf die Ukraine konzentrieren.
Aber diese ganzen Dauerkrisen, das ist ja, nicht gedacht, dass wir so viel Material
haben für Krisenbegleitung bei UKW. Aber so ist es jetzt.
Würde mir wünschen, ja, wir werden uns wünschen, wieder in Covid-Zeiten zurück.
Oh Gott, bitte. Zu sein, wenn das Ganze schief geht.
Alright, Leute, dann sagen wir jetzt Tschüss und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Wir hören uns bald wieder. Tschüss, bis bald.
Mach's gut.